[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
non
et
[Musique]
à
où
[Musique]
je
m
salut tout le monde et bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle journée de compétition
dans cette coupe des nations je suis en
direct avec romain edouard salut romain
salut kevin bonjour à tous et romain du
coup tu nous as lens est intervenu pour
pour les rondes 3 et 4 et depuis que
depuis que tu t'es assis dans la chaise
il n'y a plus qu'une seule défaite quoi
que des victoires
ouais écoute je suis très content
pourrir les deux victoires de l'équipe
de france mais malheureusement pour moi
ça veut dire que c'était pas moi le
porte bonheur à l'état pur
ça m'a fait un petit pincement au coeur
mais je les ai lancé comme ça tu étais
pas le c'était pas le porte bonheur mais
c'était là la locomotive fouet tu as
d'ailleurs tu dis équipe de france et a
comme moi hausse des prix non mais on
s'est pris au jeu à 100% on va moins que
cette équipe d'europe qui est cool et
est du coup c'est marrant surtout
qu'hier c'est maxime qui apportait le
point la victoire contre la russie donc
quelque part que ferait l'europe sans la
france absolument
bonjour à tout le monde dans le chat je
vois qu'on a déjà des petits messages
kevin oui les gens les gens sur
l'allégeance ont un petit peu fou fou
c'est parti c'est parti dans des délires
hier sur ma chaise perso et donc tu vois
ça va parler de bourhis et de un petit
peu tout dans le dans le chat et tu vois
les gens qui ont remarqué que les images
chemise préférée et c'est ce que je
disais spécialement pour 3 des revenus
tous nous apporter la victoire à chelsea
je dois faire l'effort et m maîtres la
poubelle chemise ok mais moi j'ai mis
moi j'ai mis mon plus beau polo baba on
et vous rendez vous aujourd'hui à
dévorer on va retrouver vos mais on sera
peut-être un peu moins beau d'ici une
heure et demie parce qu'on attaque par
la chine et la chine romain c'est c'est
quand même être très dur mais la chine
qui vas tu vas tu veux la jouer relax
maintenant ils sont presque le pense
qualifié mathématiquement pour la finale
et on a quand même une équipe redoutable
donc on va dire que 1,2 à 2,2 sur une
bonne opération pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui
ou peut être qu'on peut s'attendre à un
match peut-être qu'on peut s'attendre à
ce que les deux équipes ne soient pas
trop
en moins d'agressif ou alors est-ce
qu'ils vont jouer dans leur style
habituel ce qu'était ce qu'ils vont
s'envoyer est-ce qu'ils vont s'envoyer
des pièces de sacrifice de pièces comme
d'habitude mais ça pourrait les chinois
qui vont employer c'est la même
stratégie c'est-à-dire bloqué les trois
premiers à les marquer avec avec le
quatrième mais anna musi choo que
montreuil joue bien dans ce tournoi
oui mais alors aller marquer contre 1
amusé de choc c'est tout sauf une
tout sauf une assurance d'autant qu'à
l'aller blanc
donc moi c'est un match que c'est un
match que je nous vois pas perdre en
fait parce que voilà maxime en ce moment
contre digue d'irène les résultats vont
bien à renier en pleine forme il a les
blancs duda et joue du oud avec les
noirs on sait que c'est à double
tranchant music shop je pense pas
qu'elle perdra avec les blancs contre
jouve njoum je pense que ça serait pas
mal que je joue plutôt solide
effectivement mais c'est un match que je
pense qu'on va commencer est il
difficile de mettre un point évidemment
quelque part ils sont tous très fort
mais voilà je nous vois bien je dois
bien au moins ne pas perdre ce match et
ce serait je pense un très bon résultat
pour nature du mont royal un match nul
on prend et c'est vrai t'as raison de
souligner qu'à la musique jusqu'au
dernier joue bien et nana janis et sa
remplaçante aussi on est vraiment on est
vraiment forts un franchement on a eu un
peu de mal le premier jour et puis deux
puis c'est vrai qu'on en voit les matchs
sont plutôt propre depuis ce match
difficile contre l'inde en réalité ça se
passe bien
les matchs sont sont serrés mais on les
domine quoi c'est ce que je veux dire on
a cessé pas c'est pas en mode on peut
perdre ou gagner sans voix de pierre
match nul au mieux gains on est on est
toujours du bon côté du dimanche ont de
toute façon là on est en pleine
confiance on aider on est des diesel on
a commencé doucement mais maintenant je
pense que plus rien ne pourra nous
arrêter
on est on est vraiment un peu comme
l'équipe de france tu coup pour la peine
exact c'est sms labsus révélateur tout à
l'heure kevin ah ouais on marche on
marche exactement comme la france
c'est à dire que aux échecs on fait
comme dans les autres sports j'ai envie
de dire on se fait souvent peur et puis
après une fois qu'on est parti on est
parti on rase et puis on a souvent les
chats on rappelle en process ligue 1
donc au casting avec l'équipe de france
tous ses matches donc on rappelle
l'approach explique ce championnat qui
s'est jouée par internet où on avait une
équipe de france donc kevin était le
capitaine des matches qui jouait en 16
parties quatre matchs de quatre parties
et plusieurs fois on a commencé un
cependant 3 1 3 milliard 1 demi et à la
fin on perdait jamais ce match donc on
était des diesels nous aussi oui mais
même le match on a perdu en huitième de
finale contre nos amis américains
emmenés par hikaru savait qu'on avait
très mal commencé puis de même on est
bien finie fille perdue après au tie
break mais mais ça que c'est vos échecs
en tout cas c'est ça ressemble
ça ressemble vraiment à cette équipe de
france et la coupe d'europe qui fait un
peu pareil juste un petit point pour
montrer le classement aux romains à
gauche de l'écran pour bien corroborer
avec tes dires il ya plus que trois
équipes qui jouent la victoire on va
dire dans cette compétition il reste 4 4
matchs et la chine comme tu disais bien
parti mais si on gagne ce match on
pourra avoir les dents longues et
peut-être même aller chercher une
première place en phase de groupes
pourquoi pas et puis la chine 6 voiles
avec une avec une défaite contre
l'europe la chine aussi serait remise à
la portée des états unis et n'aura plus
la qualification en finale d'assurer
donc à très très gros match aussi pour
la chine contre la team europe
aujourd'hui
mais disons que comme tu disais un match
nul c'est vrai car en jeu les deux
équipes en a vraiment marre peut
s'ouvrir qu'après il n'y a pas ce genre
d'arrangement aux échecs le match va
être joué à fond mais peut-être que les
deux capitaines ont donné à leurs
joueurs la consigne d y aller mollo oui
à la tiens en parlant de capitaine qui
s'est connecté il doit il doit pas se
connecter mais il sait que nice est
déconnecté mais on l'a vu furtivement le
capitaine de l'équipe d'europe c'est
elle avec les lunettes
maxime qui nous confiait hier soir en
off sur le chat un petit peu plus tard
dans la soirée que gary n'étais pas très
confiant pour la compétition pour la
victoire finale
c'est qu'apparemment il voit aussi comme
comme nous la chine un peu au dessus
mais ma foi
alors me confier autre chose en off
quand quand il a raté le gain contre
rats de labo fier il m'a dit que je
garde lui avait demandé s'il était
possible qu'il arrête de jouer tous ses
coups en une seconde
mais bonjour l'ambiance dans l'équipe
est dans les salles garé dans l'équipe
tu peux pas à garder ça alors qu'à saint
fort caractère
c'est peut-être celui qui se prend le
plus haut je peux peut-être encore plus
que ses joueurs le plus au jeu à la
compétition gary qui est une demande
même dans le même temps les plus dans
les dents les exhibitions les plus dé -
les moins compétitifs
on voit toujours avec cette rage de
gagner et à kevin hell quand il donne
une simultanée ou qui fait des aygudes
des événements exhibition avec par
exemple des acteurs ou des sponsors avec
cetera qui fait des partis comme ça
comment pour s'amuser il veut toujours
quand même gagné si tu prends une
certaine vidéo dans sa tournée en
afrique peut-être sais pas si tu avais
vu ça sur youtube
alors ça me dit quelque chose ouais
c'était il ya peut-être euros il ya
longtemps maintenant il ya six ans
quelque chose comme ça il est allé jouer
en simultané en afrique et puis tu sais
il y avait ils avaient un peu rangé les
échiquiers par par force entre
guillemets et et il avait mis un joueur
à 2100 mais qu'ils devaient vraiment
bien joué avec des joueurs débutants ou
très amateur à 1200 1300 et gary gars
hyper la partie enfin se retrouve avec
une pièce de manque complètement perdant
et commence à faire un scandale avec les
organisateurs et joueurs exprès là il
fallait pas vous voyez bien que vous
avez rangé par force moi je vous
différemment et c'est vrai c'était alors
c'était une simultanée complètement
amical et pour présenter les échecs en
afrique mais elles ne répondent pas je
me suis je faisais référence à 7 à cette
vidéo ben en fait son avenir n'a
tellement des vidéos comme ça par
exemple il ya eu salon d'essen pas et ça
paris pendant le
le grande chaise tour quand il faisait
des faisait une exhibition donc c'est un
très grand joueur d'échecs avec une
personnalité
par exemple là comme disait un acteur
apolitique et c est la première année
celui qui s'était retrouvé kasparov
avait dit pitié plus jamais ça je veux
qu'ils aient vu qu'ils jouent en équipe
qui joue un coup chacun et à chaque fois
qu'il joue un coup le poc kasparov le
regarder comme un gamin néophyte complet
et donc du coup la deuxième année plus
personne joue l'équipe et ils ont mis
c'est celle organisateurs du tournoi et
sponsors de maxime vachier lagrave
djigbé tu as other s'était collé à la
tâche et il n'y avait pas eu
d'engueulade mais y avait il ya eu quand
même un petit mois amusant où il ya eu
une pause de trois minutes
parce que les deux pensé que c'était à
l'autre de jouer à wii j'osais pas
évident évidemment je n'osais pas
regarder hadji better n'osais pas dire à
kasparov combat qu'est ce que tu attends
joue et caspera ce jeudi c'est fou quand
même cette année jugées convenues les
consignes de pas me fâcher je t'aime un
moment il commença le regard de l ufr
des yeux et du coup c'est à kasparov de
jouer pour la pelle et tu m'apportes est
le plus jeune est sérieusement en cause
à chaque fois j'ai plus l'habitude la
fin de l'histoire
il faudrait amender je demande à gilles
du col occasion il est possible je
dirais que c'était plutôt que sport de
jouer c'est ça le plus barbare dans
l'histoire c'est que ça devait être à
kasparov sinon j'ai bien servi et gym de
marie-josée fait très très attention
donc attention tu avais savais que ça va
peut être mais c'est pas c'est pas
marrant quatre ans mais ceci pour ça
qu'on aime
ah mais oui c'est ce qui a fait sa force
aussi c'est ce qui a fait de lui un
champion du monde a cette chance de
caractère de rien laisser au hasard de
pas même une partie simultanée comme tu
disais ne pas vouloir la laisser passer
voilà il voulait c'est quelqu'un qui
veut gagner toutes ces parties s'il va
s'asseoir sur un banc dans un parc c'est
pour gagner
et le fait qu'il soit semi retraités on
va dire même retraité complètement ne
change rien quand on voit la sortir
alors qu'ils les réinviter pour un
tournoi exhibition ou pour être
capitaine
de l'équipe d'europe il veut du résultat
est incroyable en plus assez en train de
démarrer un je vais ouvrir les
échiquiers mais ce qui est un croyant
plus sur cette simultanée que c'est que
c'était pendant les élections il s'était
présenté au poste de président de la
fide et et en fait même la une partie
d'échecs était plus important que la
diplomatie ou à que ce soit c c'est
trouve ça extraordinaire parce que c'est
que c'est quelqu'un d'entier quoi alors
on peut aimer ne pas aimer ya certaines
choses que j'aime pas évidemment comme
comme tout le monde mais en soi c'est un
côté d'un côté un côté marrant après il
ya des choses moins marrante mais on en
parlera peut-être pendant la pause
peut-être bien
peut-être bien alors on a un système
qu'on a un système qu'on appelle le
système colle avec les blancs romain
alors oui un essai non c'est pas
vraiment un système colin parce que le
pion eric ans et 4 vient de systèmes
coll oui c'est un système que le début
mais vu qu'il a joué ses cartes on est
retombé dans une espèce de stade en fait
de smith la ddt où les systèmes cole le
pion reste en c2 ou vendant ces trois
donc moins gluant donc ouais c'est des
positions où les blancs jouent pour des
avantages minimaux et qu'un va jouer aux
quatre ou cinq un moment donné et la
position va en général se terminer par
un avantage très symbolique pour les
blancs à tous les trois ce qui va jouer
cinq ou préparée par la tour e 8 ou
prendre ces quatre pour jeu 5 je sais
pas trop à un moment il va réagir au
centre de toute façon tous ici jouent
avec des six baies -celles j'imagine est
exactement malheur baissier sylla serait
peut-être quatre je sais pas même
patrick bessy sais je vois parfois des
parties gens qui font ça web et 6 ou
bessette la d'annoncer cette solide
aussi pourquoi vous en lui cet argent ou
être pour venir échanger le flou et le
flou et b2 avec x 3 ouais moi souvent je
suis partisan ma presse un goût
personnel d'essayer de prendre en c4 et
faire 5
c'est un peu plus dynamiques ouais parce
que si on fait 5 évidemment on se laisse
après un échange en d5 puis un échange a
eu 5
on se laisse avec un pion isolé francs
un aigle une emprise est par exemple par
exemple petit rock qu'on se laisse avec
quelques points isolés en d5 alors là
dans cette version précise est ce que
les notes jouées des quatre je ne sais
pas pour essayer donc un peu isolé c'est
un pion qui n'a pas de qui ne peut pas
être protégé par un autre pion donc là
voilà le pion des 5 et isolée par
exemple et si on arrivait à placer un
cavalier juste devant le cavalier
bloqueurs en d4
on partira du principe que les blancs
ont un petit avantage seulement ici à ce
que les noirs peuvent l'idée c'est tout
liquider avec des quatre je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas c'est pour expliquer
romain à peu près le type de positions
auxquelles ça arrive donc là je serai un
pion isolé si les noirs s'en débarrasse
ils égalisent si les blancs réussissent
à le bloquer il y aura un petit
inconvénient à long terme on va
retourner sur le direct et maxime qui a
joué 5 justement
donc cessons on a de la chance romain
puisque ce qu'on était en train
d'expliquer va arriver sur sur
l'échiquier comme ça ils vont pouvoir
l'expliquer mieux que nous oui c'est le
parfait en espérant que ce soit maxime
qui explique un petit peu mieux que ding
d'irène du coup histoire donne envie de
dire à mon avis ce qu'ont à l'avant se
tromper ce cas pas depuis on prend 1,5
car elle les prend 2,5
ici à mon avis les blancs ne reprennent
pas sur le fond 1 5 et 2 trop dynamique
on a vu ici et blanche quelque chose je
sois tout peut-être quelque chose qu'un
match 3 pour éviter faut aux quatre fous
de d'ailleurs pour pour pas peindre
d'albert de cloud vers de fou dont on y
parlait ouais c'était pas si grave je
pense que si tu perds la perte de fou
mais fo est tout à fait naturel donc le
fou qui s'est d'abord développée en d3 1
mais après ce changement de structure
il se ravise qui vient à eux deux et
c'est un peu mieux aussi pour la
protection du roi d'avoir un fou ensuite
être pas plutôt que en d3 c'est à dire
efira pas de clouage pour pour faire
semblant d agréables où croiser là en
plus à perdre est tout de suite parce
qu'on fait cavaler prendre 5 menace de
pranger caté chauffe ou prend 1,2
reprendrait du cavalier et là surprise
surprise de fougue et deux protège de
cavaliers qui en a gagné une pièce
complète alors maxime j'espère qu'il va
pas faire ça mais ça ce serait étonnant
il a pris en est trois prix en f3 et tu
vois il est venu en 5 quand même avec le
fou pour pour se mettre dans ce visage
parce que tu expliquer juste avant
peut-être pousser des quatre si le
peuple à ses hommes mais là je crois pas
qu'il va pouvoir maintenant parce que
des quatre je pense qu'ils auraient
cavaliers b5 tout simplement
et le problème c'est que l'option des
quatre est cloué à cause de fou prend ou
oui et ça ferait et ça ferait une pièce
de plus pour les blancs de plus pour les
blancs alors talange essayer de faire
marcher des quatre parce que sans le
foin f3 il y avait des cavaliers g4 il y
avait des coudes attaque finale au fond
avec 3 est vraiment très très bien placé
et donc à mon avis des cats est pas
possible du tout et donc magasinage ou
autrement
merci qui va même devoir envoie en plus
dans les pièces blanches bien placé un
le fouet froid qui tape le pion
lecavalier qui le tape aussi la dame
dont il ya trois pièces déjà qu'ils
regardent ce pion heureusement j'ai
envie de dire romain que le que le fou
ou cinq coups le cavalier c3 j'ai envie
de te dire que maxime à mon avis regarde
ses positions avec une fois de
philosophie complètement différente de
n'importe quel autre joueur du monde je
vais t'expliquer pourquoi parce que
c'est un joueur de une fade et pendant
que les autres c'est dire est mince
comment je défends cette faiblesse en d5
maximilien 30 se demander comment ils
pourraient la sacrifier maillot
proximité en train de se dire avec comme
enjeu peut forcément l'adversaire à
prendre ses pions et obtenir de
l'initiative
là je pense qu'ils pensent que ils
pensent qu'à une chose c'est à jouer
j'avais jir justement à jouer des coups
actif comme fouet f5 est pas fou et
aussi pour défendre le pion paisiblement
du voyage aux actifs
ah mais c'est souvent bien avec le tueur
isolé un peu comme ça ouais tout à fait
car à pompe tête il va jouer
tranquillement chaud aux quatre derrière
pour pour échanger quelques pièces génie
sur la ligne 4 bien discuté pendant très
longtemps de ce pur isolé avec avec le
le spécialiste français de la structure
de pions vladislav quatre clubs peuvent
laddh international est le fameux bladé
ouais donc lui un éminent spécialiste de
la structure de pions reconnu gens me
dire internationalement vraiment pour la
fête c'est pas une blague et il me
disait un truc fondamental il ya
beaucoup de joueurs qui prennent le pion
isolé comme une faiblesse et il disait
c'est pas vrai à 100% et glisser une
faiblesse qui confère de l'activité donc
il jette un peu qu'on peut utiliser
comme une force one mission qui nous a
été posée dans le chatt kevin c'est
qu'est ce qui se passait à la passe deux
fois que 5,6 les noirs jouer dames c'est
cette parce qu'il y avait une double
attaque sur le cavalier c3 et le pion h
2 mais a priori simplement cavale et
prend des 5 et sur la vallée prend des
cinq on échange d'abord 5 puis on
reprend des cinq et on a gagné un pion
est là même si maxime je le disais a
peut-être envie de sacrifier sion pour
l'initiative
là y aurait pas d initiative oui donc
fou fsam dan d2 donc maxime qui peut
c'est vrai joué sur cette case de quatre
ans le pion isolé qui confèrent une case
une case for temps de quatre et qui
donne un avantage des espaces donc
maxime en jouant de manière active peut
réussir à égaliser en force d'ailleurs
l'ordinateur propose le coup cavalcade
dont tu parlais un car elle est ou
quatre qui imaginent provoquer est ce
que les blancs prendrait du cavalier
probablement puis on prend et on prend
la pression elle change les dames là on
a quand même un peu en avance avec thé
blanc fou 35.93 mon install le fond h3
ici pour bloquer l'avancée du roi et on
devrait avoir assez de jeu pour faire
annuler siècle et noir peut-être pas le
change tout de suite tu voulais pas tu
peux aussi faire ça je rappelais
j'aurais pensé à six mois et sept mois
tranquillement on a été sûrement veut
ramener le ramener le roi tranquillement
salindroise c'est pas mal ça veut
peut-être raison de changer une paire de
tours avait peut-être raison
c'était pour essayer de rentrer en fait
je lui disais juste pour expliquer le
chat le petit truc auquel je pense et
c'est le fou couvent la case 17 donc ça
me semblait sympa voilà il dit notre
idée ça serait de d'échangés la deuxième
paire de tours et ensuite le matériel en
foot que leur poser le matériel serait
trop réduit pour que les blancs plus
espérer gagner surtout avec un mois
enfermés comme ça angers 1
c'est un petit plus pour les blancs mais
ça peut être le genre de variantes dont
tu parlais justement quand tu disais
maxime qui regardent les changes des
pièces pour perdre un regard de
l'activité ou les échanges de pièces
perdre un put avoir assez d'activité
c'est le genre d'idée que maxime va
avoir absolument absolument hilarant
semble calculé cavalier e 4 c'est sûr il
ya aussi en train de calculer tour ses
huit des choses comme ça à mon avis
puisque cac et prend des cinq n'est pas
encore une menace
je crois que quoique fou prend b2 dame
prend b2 cavale dépens des saints que
j'allais dire ont gagné une pièce mais
il ya toujours des uns ici ou quatre
avec un retour d un père un vendéen peur
des impairs autour d un père à cause de
9,6 c'est joli ça tourne bien qu'ils
voulaient jouer sur le clouage et dan f6
qui des gourous attaque la dame et en
cas de dame prend dame de coeur bat des
records de la colonne des très jolies
très joli piège quatre messages papa
qu'il ya du coup vont prendre et par
exemple dans le quatre mois la pièce
voilà ici ça devrait être pas être grand
chose de fou peut-être un tout petit peu
meilleur que cavalier mais bon pas grand
chose
alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans la
partie maxime qui réfléchit toujours
digby ioane qui joue vite est ce que ça
pourrait être une préparation dingli
reine aux heures d'ouverture simple
d'irlande france
oui parce que tous les goûts on était
naturel de la part des deux côtés donc
je pense que ding irène est préparé à
l'aura peut-être sur un tour sur les
autres partis pendant que maxime
réfléchi tout à fait tout à fait romain
alors on va est ce que je trouve bon jeu
on va prendre le le dou da en premier
puisque ses premiers qui me tombait sous
la souris avec les noirs contre yu yang
i une position qui ressemble ni nous au
bon début de partie avec la même chose
dans le foot est un qui est resté englué
dans les pionts exactement et les blancs
qui ont joué à trois des quatre pour
bloquer la poussée ces cinq et on
retrouve ce même thème en fait que dans
la partie de maxime silenor jouent ces
cinq trop tôt on va voir multiples
échanges de pion à ses 5 et les normes
vont se retrouver avec un pion isolé en
d5
on peut l'illustrer 1 je suis vraiment
le fond b2 pareil on va voir que divisée
que ça ressemble à valence
sèmassi par exemple cavaliers b5 pour
mettre le cavalier en d4 bloqueurs et là
les blancs sont un petit peu mieux moins
c'est ce que les gens souhaitent obtenir
mais les noirs sont pas obligés de jouer
ces cinq évidemment mais c'est ses
positions qui peuvent qui peuvent se
ressembler et c'est quoi c'est un petit
plus pour les blancs ou même pas alors
là ça va ça va dépendre ce qu'il faut ça
va dépendre si les blancs arrive à bien
à bien organiser leur pièce c'est pas
facile dans cette position là de trouver
un plan pour les blancs s'il arrive par
exemple à fixer avec b 5 à 4 ça peut
être un petit avantage pour les blancs
mais il faut pouvoir reprendre d'un pion
en b5 donc par exemple ici b5 lenor
jouerait à 6 et après à 4
j'en prends le dessin qu'on ne pourrait
pas prendre du plomb à cause de la tour
1 et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on veut
pas donc un bon coup de préparation en
principe ces tours b un ton bien qui en
plus un pêche complètement ses 5 à cause
de bp france et 5
et voilà
et l'option b est cloué tourbe est un
pur pour jouer b5 et a4 éventuellement
fixer parfois ça ça peut donner un petit
avantage pour le blanc intéressant
intéressant intéressant romain est ce
que les noirs peut essayer de jouer sur
cette case de 4 ou le carré 18 mois est
absolument ils peuvent jouer sur la case
ou 4 ils peuvent aussi pourquoi pas
faire du g6 h5 je viens me plonge 5h
côté cherche qu'à chasser le cavalier
c'est plus risqué évidemment et voit les
peuples a joué solide par exemple jouer
à 6 tranquillement la nuisance pour
continuer dans ton idée sur à 4 en fait
si les nord veut jouer veulent un petit
peu stériliser les dames il joue ses six
danseuses joueurs de position ça enferme
le fourbe et cette part est pas très
joli mais l'idée est simple c'est que
sur bessin qu'on va faire puis on prend
des 5 comprend des cinq c5 et il ya plus
de prises en passant puisque le pian le
pion vient pas de ses 7 mai de ces 5
donc il n'ya pas de dépenser 6 et cette
position est très bonne pour les noirs
là tu menaces cela tu vas
ces 4 6 se passe rien qui peut être une
idée si prends tu reprends est à deux
pions liés au centre de très virulente
cavaliers qui arrivera en b si cela les
normes une position idéale
donc après ces six voilà ça tu bloques
un petit peu la position le
l'inconvénient c'est bien ce fou
bessette
mais toutes les autres pièces des noirs
sont assez bien coordonné donc c'est
quelque chose
voilà ce quelque chose que possible et
peut-être que à 5 peut arriver aussi
maintenant puisque b 5 ans jouera quand
même c'est ça je dire à 5 des noirs la
5e à 5 des ventes possible aussi et
effectivement jours à b5 on a un petit
peu tout bloquer et le foot m'a
complètement fermée en b 7 mai retour un
jour va rejoindre aucune va repartir ans
et 8 aces à ces structures à la
structure carlsbad
c'est classique va être le pion à 5 très
importante ce qu'il évite qu'elle valait
8,6 et 10,6 et j'aime pas tant que ça
parce que les blancs vont à mon avis
rapidement joué avec trois ou quatre là
ça me fait pas trop ça ce serait
celle-là c'est l'avantagé d'avoir le
cavaliere g3 et parents f3 comme dans la
plupart de carlsbad
ouais mais laïque et angers 3 qui permet
de plonger sièges trois ou quatre ans il
en avait trois mais c'est une position
c'est très complexe dont
je crois pas me tromper en disant que
les normes spécialiste de cette
structure de pioncer magnus carlsen un
petit moi m'impressionne à chaque fois
qu'ils ont là entre les mains mais katie
effectivement effectivement il les
maîtrise mais maîtrisent à la perfection
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres comme
notre parti kevin alors qu'est-ce qu'on
a ça juste le coup en cours pour dire
ces dames b3 qui a été jouée alors les
autres par cuba écoute il faut qu'on
trouve à on a un à musique tubes pour
avancer les bonnes que j'arrive pas à
trouver mais on à ana ana avec les
blancs une partie qui pourrait être
déterminante elle c'était une française
des changes alors pain nan c'est pas une
française des changes à ça à transposer
dans une française des changes via
absolue d3 et d4 et du coup ce sera du
coup française des changes c'est rigolo
hockey et 7,7 digne à la mode
d'accord a été jouée par les joueurs
français un satiné kg 5.6 de mémoire
ouais j'ai l'impression que c'est
étienne nom kick aime bien cette
variante est 11e qui a lancé ça ouais
etienne bacrot une accro à lille demain
note le pion au f4 ont eu à cava de' des
quatre ne peut pas nécessaire de laisser
faire ça mais ses actifs en tout cas
c'est compliqué at vous pas la serrure à
côté côté blanc anna non mais fou mais
j'ai peur que vous prend 1,4 à mes
qualités car les 4 sur 5 à tourcoing est
fiat
ouais alors même ça est ce que ce soit
si grave je joue gamme c7 faire revenir
et 2,10 on web meurent là ça va
justement s'égaliser les noirs sont même
peut-être un tout petit peu mieux avec
un cavalier qui arrive en 4 je suis pas
convaincu par ce sacrifice de pion à 4
mais bon tu aurais plutôt frais g3 plus
tranquille mouais on va regarder
l'option grand au rock même si j'aurais
probablement trop tôt tyrol ils
devraient se lèveront les vannes aronian
alors 9 me
alors là je suis pas convaincu par ce
qu'il a fait avec des blancs à 32,01
noir un buteur de l'équipe l'homme en
forme au sol y mar
donc il donne la paire de flou il laisse
le fou g7 bien actif sur les grandes
diagonales structure de pions un taux
supérieur pour les blancs mêlés nos
rangs la paire de fou pour compenser et
la possibilité à un moment donné de
jouer des cinq aussi je pense pas que
les banques puissent à ce par l avantage
ici mais bon on disait on disait déjà ça
avant-hier et il a fini par gagner notre
mini des vannes donc laissons le
laissant le nous donner un coup port
brèche j'ai envie qu'on lui fasse
confiance à level 1 ouais absolument
alors on maxime ou là j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya une gaffe
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a fait
dames 16 alors j'avais dit qu'il fait
j'avais dit qu'il allait donner ce pion
avec j'espérais qu'il le donne de façon
un peu plus convaincante quand même il a
raté quelque chose dans maxim qu'est-ce
qu'il a raté parce que c'est un plein
mois est d'accord de foot
il a réfléchi assez longtemps il a pris
six minutes 16 il a fait dames 7 qui
perd un pion aux dérives dingli rennes
était surpris halak briefing 30 et puis
il a pris le pion bêtement un qu'est ce
qu'il a pu rater maxime ce par 5 d'un
point ça paraît délirant qu'est ce qu'il
a pu rater coup de fatigue je sais pas
c'est un peu moi c'est complètement
perdre on est contre un joueur comme
ding ça normalement il ya vraiment zéro
chance de s'en sortir c'est tôt dans
cette gaffe 1 de la part de maxime y en
a pas d'homme 7 le pion de cinq étaient
même pas attaquer du coup il a peut-être
oublié qu'en vendant nos sept îles à
celle +15 probablement s'adresse à mon
avis c'est pas une faute de calcul dans
une mare en tout cas là je pense c'est
vraiment
by très tôt dans une variante 1 comme tu
dit dano 7 parce que cavalier prend des
salles de toute façon tu ne peux pas
prendre en b2 la dame étant prises donc
tu es obligé prendre ça c'est fort c'est
fou prend 1,5 et ici je vois pas ce que
maxime aurait pu oublier sur d'un procès
qui avait à me prendre et 5
ouais c'est pas un c'est
incompréhensible caméra écoute c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est ça qui est
beau dans le sport aussi un romain c'est
que même les meilleurs même les
meilleurs du monde sont capables de
faire des erreurs d'un batteur
absolument là c'est vraiment une erreur
il est rare qu'il lui arrive jamais
normalement ce genre de deux fautes de
photos calcule aussi basique a surtout
qu'il a pris le temps s'est signalé pris
10 20 secondes on aurait pu dire oui
mais il a juste oublié là elle a pris
six minutes c'est qu'il a vraiment eu le
temps de peser le pour et le contre mais
il a ses dreads vraiment comme tu dis il
a dû oublier que le pion était en prise
est à noter aussi qu'il s'est pas une
structure de pions qui joue forcément
souvent le pion isolé avec les noirs
alors peut-être aussi le tu sais que tu
sais pas pour toi si ça fait pareil mais
j'ai l'impression que dans les positions
qu'on vous souvent on a un genre de deux
radars non qui est toujours allumée
absolument absolument
mais comme je disais le radar de maxime
ces jeux sacrifier un plan pour les
initiatives
il n'avait pas le bon radar d'allumer da
dans cette position ouais bon une partie
qui se passe mal ça veut dire qui a fait
remarquer quelque part alors comment tu
joues dans ce genre de situations avec
maintien - n'êtes pas de pas de
compensation qu'est-ce que tu
recommandes de faire dans ces cas là
gardé les pièces sur l'échiquier au
contraire les échanger pour essayer de
rentrer dans une finale nul
comment tu comment tu gères ça parce que
tu peux pas abandonner tout comme fait
maxime kf4 c'est bien joué mais
évidemment la f3 va être joué je ne
m'attends à un thème menace maintenant
main attention dans le projet de maths
qui surprend il faut sûrement joué tout
reprend là ça pourrait aller et là ça
pourrait aller enfin ça distrait moins
bien mais récupéré son pion est sûre kf4
f3 est ce qu'il peut faire
car il y eut ce repère tout reprend des
quatre noms des quatre pas du tout les
gens quelque chose comme ça j'ai même un
nom wayne aussi une qualité moins ça
marche pas du tout je suis relax 3 ça
veut dire qu'il a prévu de jouer dam des
trois peut pas quoi d'autre d'amd 5-1
d'amd 5 et revenir ont aussi c'est
effectivement son cavalier sera moins
bien plaçant le 6 peut-être f5 pour
éviter que les noirs et les blancs
pousse trop facilement leur majorité
pions sa contrôler la case d'entrée ans
et 7 pour la tour donc le cavaly est
bien passé en russie se rappelle un
petit peu le cavalier hier de l'even
contre dominguez wii qui contrôle un
petit peu touret m'écoute
c'est lé pourcentage de chance de la
sauver sont minces mais c'est pas encore
abandon non plus un côté français c'est
pas encore abandon des blancs peuvent
surprendre f4 toutes les chances d'un
des cartels entre une tendance est cette
finale deux tours probablement gagnante
mais bon c'est pas fini vc 25 b5 d'abord
pour pas donné le pion non plus ouais
dur mais ouais ça se passe pas bien ça
c'est sûr mais encore quelques petites
chances de s'en sortir
même s'ils comptent des migraines mon
principe c'est pas le bon client pour
rater ce genre de davantage mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres
donc on avait donc il a remis le
cavaliere au 6 juillet à voyager une
finale avec un plan de moins le chat
rigoler un petit peu un de ses conseils
de gars y réfléchit bien avant de
voiliers réfléchie des ados minutes
pourvu d'un no 7 et pas fin donc non
maxime vaut mieux porter joue vite faut
qu'il revienne sur nos conseils de base
1 ne réfléchit pas ne calcule pas je
vais au feeling ça se passe ça se passe
beaucoup mieux comme ça romain alors
écoute faut qu'on aille chercher un
point quelque part je propose qu'on
fasse un petit tour rapide on garde
maxime à la caméra quand même qui a
l'air un peu dubitatif alors est-ce que
le point il peut venir de tout ça il ya
cette fameuse structure de pions 1 sauf
que le pion blanc et par yvan à 5 et
mamadou baïla d'où des mélanges tout il
a laissé les blancs prendre l'initiative
et poussé 5 f4 comme ça et il a fait
mais non ça va pas du tout et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ne nous fait un peu
comme max signé c'est de jouer
s'ils jouent les nouvelles positions et
du coup ils essaient de jouer des coups
très actif d'un côté de l'échiquier où
il devrait juste jouer tranquille quoi
mais là il va se brassent la regarde
toutes les pièces qui rayonne côté blanc
alain le roy
bon il se passe pas terrible ce match
pour le moment est un as et espérons
tous pro f 4 ne va pas être joué parce
que fourie f 4 salaires dépassent et
égalisant quand même et on a besoin
d'elle alors attends attends attends
attends tanger une nouvelle on va tenter
un truc très technique
on va tenter un truc très très technique
à mon cher romain je vais avoir besoin
d'une chose de ta part
c'est que tu meubles sur une position
que je vais te mettre sans que je touche
l'échiquier et peut-être que tu pourras
plus voir non plus alors quelle position
on va se dire celle là c'est là donc oui
malheureusement fou prend un f4 a été
joué et après cavaliers des quatre on
avait dit qu'ils avaient eu 5 mai fu 7
c'est pas mal non plus et après par
exemple cavaliers prend aussi sur un fou
b6 échec la tour va venir en huit ans
quatre cavaliers des quatre il y aura au
minimum pour les noirs un échange en d4
qui aplanit complètement la position
donc là j'ai peur que on aille vers une
nulle malheureusement ce qui serait pas
très content pour le match au vu de la
situation
donc si on compte les points romain ça
voudrait dire qu'on serait déjà sur deux
défaites 8 nuls on a déjà quasiment
match perdu face à cette équipe chinoise
avant d'avoir commencé
ça se passe un petit peu comme la
première fois qu'on les a joués c'est à
dire que
mauvais début de match est très très
mauvais début de match j'ai
effectivement mais duda on a vu qu'il
était capable de n'importe quoi et puis
maxime on sait qu'il est capable aux six
un très très grand défenseur
donc finalement il n'y a encore aucune
partie qui est terminée mais
effectivement pour l'instant voilà on a
deux mauvaises positions et deux
positions égal en quoi de très mauvaise
position
alors je vois qu'ils évitent en train de
tenter d âge temps quelque chose là tout
le sens que va être très très
agréablement surpris
là je tente quelque chose qui peut nous
mettre alors peut-être détrompe-toi
robin tu m'as jamais tendu tente un tel
geste technique c'est un geste technique
qui pourrait très mal se finir d'accord
donc ça se trouve une vingt secondes ses
adieux à jamais c'est ça c'est à son
comble donc au cas où tu sais quoi qui
est donc je vais faire un petit point
qui peut sur les autres matchs ratés
fois que l'équipe de france alors on a
le match
donc vous pouvez pas voir les positions
sauf si vous les regardez par vous même
et vous les regrette pas sûr sur notre
écran à nous nakamura qui al'avantage
contre nepomniachi dans le match états
unis russie qui est un match très
important aussi parce que l'équipe qui
remportera ce match sera la seule à
avoir une petite chance théorique de
d'accrocher la finale et a priori
davantage davantage donc qu attend donc
je regarde toutes les parties ok donc au
deuxième et chic et caruana très très
solide avec et noir contre artemiev au
troisième et chic et wesley so position
pas clair contre contrecarre yakine ou
pra blanc pas davantage pour les
américains et côté gorillaz qui
n'accroche aux dernières échiquier à
tout petit avantage pour les blancs donc
un match pas claire pour le moment un
match pas clair peut-être un tout petit
tout petit avantage au bo américain
quoique quoique je donne un petit
avantage à kariat king quand même donc
on va match paquet à un match pas clair
et le match 1 de compte reste du monde
très intéressant de voir de voir ce
match avec à nantes qui a un net
avantage contre radjabov vie dit avec
les noirs qui a à priori une bonne
position contre fille rosa avec krishna
avec les blancs qui semble aussi
nettement mieux contre corps y ait une
position égal au dernier chic hier entre
musique zouk et arica donc un gros
avantage pour l'inde qui pourrait gagner
avec un gros score 3-3 et demi contre le
reste du monde ce qui serait une bonne
nouvelle enfin notre pari serait pas
venu une bonne veine une mauvaise
nouvelle non pour nous pondre pour nous
c'est égal tant qu'on voit que l'un
d'eux l'un des landes et dangereuse à on
préfère les avoir et on préfère que son
qu'il se soit pas trop qu'ils soient le
plus loin de nous possible au niveau du
classement mais là on a quand même bien
pris le large avec eux les deux vies de
quatre victoires précédentes donc a
priori le résultat de ce match devrait
pas trop influencer notre place finale
mais attention quand même soyons
prudents alors mon geste technique n'a
pas fonctionné mais il va peut-être
fonctionner plus tard mais on est on est
on n'a pas eu la catastrophe pente
espérait peut-être pour certains un
résident j'avoue que j'avoue que même
moi j'avais envie de voir ce que ça
pouvait donner cette catastrophe
je suis sûr que tu veux a résolu assez
rapidement on est très curieux en tout
cas ça aurait pu être une perte d'une
perte du son mais
kiné qui n'est pas arrivé ok mais on va
voir ça peut être marcher donc maxime
toujours aussi malin maxime toujours
aussi mal baronian qui maintenant est un
peu mieux donc tu vois je il fallait lui
faire confiance à des raisons kevin je
fais confiance à mon livre j'ai envie de
la paix mon les vols mais ça ça fait
tellement plaisir que les voies de
réussite dans ce tournoi franchement
c'est vraiment un bonheur de le voir
dans l'avenir à ce niveau et mieux cette
chose qu'un petit avantage maintenant
parce qu'elle n'a pas joué tout b6 échec
juventud c'est très étonnant la
structure de pions ici avec ce encore
une fois sur le pion isolé en 2,5 alors
c'est vraiment un avantage très très
symbolique pour les blancs mais voilà
sur cavaliers prend 1,6 au 20e coup moi
je m'attendais plutôt à foug b6 échec à
la petite et c'est bien là hier pour que
l'échangé de cavaliers se fasse plutôt
sur la case des quatre oui ça aurait pu
être ça aurait pu être quelque chose de
plus intéressant cinq races il fou mais
s'il faut en arrivant b3 qui est pas de
cavaillon yathrib ont attaqué la
faiblesse le flamber toi peut-être pas
quatre à cinq je faisais pas 4 ici aussi
ouais c'est je sais pas en tout cas ça
joue pour moi on à la casse des quatre
c'est déjà ça donc ça attendra on va se
faire un petit résumé donc jouanne john
peut-être on a une petite chance de
titre pression est-ce que doute à peu
nous faire un une défense de génie
comique comme il nous en avait fait une
si tu te rappelles contrarie krishna
contre l'inde pas que compte à 6 été
contrainte de paris christine affective
et là c'est exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'ils aient une position
dans laquelle il est tellement mal que
ça soit pas surprenant que les blancs et
sacrifier une pièce pour obtenir cette
position là tellement leur attaque est
forte et les blancs ou obtenues
gratuitement cette position sans le
moindre sacrifice donc l'un on peut
vraiment parler d'une partie
catastrophique de duda et
il va falloir effectivement qu'ils
défendent bien et il va falloir un petit
coup de main de son adversaire aussi
sinon ça suffira pas là on voit il ya
des menaces comme fois ci ce qu'elle
valait h5 pour aller mater le roi noir
ça parle à ce qu'il entre allumettes
c'est plutôt un coup de pied mal la fois
je sis regarde juste un scénario pour
pour faire un peu rire les gens
même là il ya peut-être d'autres choses
hein mais juste pour montrer ça c'est
matin voilà ça c'est une des seules ça
fait partie des choses qui peuvent
arriver
c'est juste pour montrer une variante
simple nom mais la dou da ilha structure
de pions il n'a pas du tout maîtrisée
important faut réviser ses classiques
on a vu notre ami gary n'est pas très
content de ce genre de prestation à
bagarry les vieilles parties d'aller
keane capablanca tartas caubère et toute
la bande il a dû les analyser et sur
analyser et doit pas comprendre comment
c'est possible de six matches joués de
carlsbad non à mon avis il est en train
de lui commander un bouquin sur internet
une entente chercher un truc sur eux en
train de chercher un truc son site de
structures de pion à bouquin de partis
classiques est évalué à la fin il va lui
balancer lui dire bon hop tu as deux
heures pour le lire et entendre
d'ailleurs tour en stock non sur le
carlsbad non mais non il va être passé
un appel aussi connaît fêtes d'akwa elle
pour le commander un livre qui n'existe
pas encore peut-être y avait cette idée
cette histoire quand il ya eu le match à
nantes kasparov le match à nantes
topalov à nantes avait perdu une finale
de foot que leur oppose nuls alors
difficile avec un pion de moi etc
mais nulle et l'anecdote dit que
kasparov l'avait appelé il y avait fait
deux heures de cours de sur les finales
de foot que leur opposer pendant son
match que sun même que ça ne se
reproduise plus monsieur ouais c'est
marrant c'est marrant un final fou de
couleurs opposées qui sont
on pense souvent qu'elles sont toutes
nul mais c'est loin d'être si simple
hein c'est pas c'est pas toujours si
c'est effectivement y'a moyen de il ya
moyen de se tromper alors là les pions
la marée blanche de dingli rennes qui la
muraille de chine est en train d'avancer
doucement mais sûrement sur le pauvre
froide maxime avec le four b2 ça
pourrait finir en attaque de maths aussi
malgré le manoir et attention quand même
cavalier g5 et si j'arrive à te faire f
si c'est que la fcc ira mieux non-cash
qu'à toi c'est plutôt bien joué car et
h7
bon c'est vrai qu'on attache pensait
qu'il avait le temps de faire quatre
cavaliers f 6 5 mais il est vrai qu'il
ya le pion h4 emprise ouais la position
dont la position reste pas bonne mais
bon ça maxime toujours en vie on va dire
ouais maxime encore en vie et donc
polish fighter mon avis c'est sûr qu'il
va perdre je vois pas dans quel monde
ils s'en sort pauli schweiter ça se
bosse pas très bien effectivement et les
bonnes
devon j'ai l'impression encore d'un
quart d'heure avant ça la pendule là si
je vois bien sur ton écran il a l'air
d'être cité d'ailleurs d'être mieux
champion passé en un an de 5 ans bientôt
être chassés et j'adore ce fou b6 romain
qui couvre la diagonale la diagonale
noir là la case f2 les tours qui a
j'adore la position de léonie là il a
transformé un morceau de caillou en
diamant la salle bondée le problème
c'est que j'ai peur qu'il ait fait une
petite heure je pense qu'il est je pense
qu'il va oublier un petit piège je pense
que les noirs sur tours c'est un peuvent
jouer aux quatre sacrifier le pion et
surtout ses cinq attention gros piège
dame prend ses cinq tours français 5 fu
des quatre échecs ouachin il va
permettre de couloir tour f1 tours
pontault reprend ce qui veut dire que
sur quatre il faudrait faire tout
reprendre le 4 mai je suis pas convaincu
au retour prendre quatre menaces tour 6
tours f5 pour attaquer des 5
pour dire leur tour tout simplement ce
saint je pensais que ça aurait de
l'initiative mais peut-être peut-être
pas peut-être qu'il l'a vu un et que
c'est un con tre piège de les vannes par
contre piège c'est à dire qu'ici si les
larges ou peu quatre ils sont un sacré
de toute façon avec tous ces cinq pages
écrit quoi la caution qui doit le temps
il doit de jouer de toute façon tous les
huit ou c'est pas joli ça j'ai confiance
j'ai confiance en les vols les vols qui
est un monstre vraiment incroyable dans
cette compétition heureusement qu'on a
ce joueur inquiets
leader incontestable et incontesté de
l'équipe 1 oui oui oui
effectif effectivement quoique quoi que
ce soit maxime qui est apporté le point
décisif contre la russie hier série
bones il ya un score impressionnant
effectivement même si d'après lui joue
pas si bien que ça dans ce tournoi mais
d'après nous il joue plutôt pas mal
écoute qui continua va jouer comme ça on
prend on est d'accord absolument
absolument énormes efforts évidents la
prochaine fois qu'on ne croise les
doigts elle est bonne ce n'était pas
super vraiment tu nous a déçus dans
cette compétition après l'es22 quelqu'un
qui aime bien faire des blagues
faire des blagues comme ça quand on
quand un journaliste ou à l'interviewer
lui pose une question il aime bien des
fois raconté n'importe quoi et derrière
ça me fait rigoler il raconte ça ira
comme ça tout le monde
je me rappelle d'une interview il avait
dit oui mon gros problème c'est les
ouvertures c'est terrible je connais
rien et c'est alors que tout le monde
sait très bien et surtout à cette époque
là en plus c'était peut-être un des
joueurs les mieux préparés au monde
d'aujourd'hui toujours mais à l'époque
à l'époque il était même au dessus de
caruana et tous ces joueurs là et donc
il y avait fait cette petite blague et
tous les maux dire que tous les joueurs
d'échecs confirmé savez bien que qui
racontait n'importe quoi ni heureux et
ça mais ça l'amusait c'est celle evans
c'est comme ça je me rappelle d'une fois
où il était allé à commenter une finale
lors d'un ton à deux des candidats en
direct et il s'amusait à faire croire
que la finale tour trois pions contours
deux pions et ai été gagnante alors
qu'elle était nulle et comme ils étaient
plus forts que les joueurs qui
commentait bien évidemment il
réussissait à les réfuter à chaque fois
à gagner mais ce qu est ce qu en plus il
y avait pas un hack amoureux cette
conférence de presse parce qu'il avait
battu nakamura justement oui finale deux
tours
ouais en fait complètement nul ouais
c'est ça c'est ça j'ai dit oui s'est
amusé à troller pendant le super combiné
ok donc là incomplète égalisation de
jouve enjoy
je pense qu'ici il faut jouer tour des
uns ou quelque chose comme ça pour
protéger le fou detroit et les noirs une
position très confortable sans doute pas
davantage faut pas exagérer mais la
position est égal donc on a deux
mauvaises positions et une bonne
position
donc ça passera forcément par un parent
un exploit de maxime dans cette finale
et la chose écoute qui fait plaisir aux
mains quand même c'est que maxime il a
filé un pion pour rien mais regarde la
jauge on en a parlé de cette jauge pour
mon les premiers les premiers jours et
vous avez dit tant qu'elle a tant
qu'elles ne dépassent pas ceux 5la
attend qu'elle dépasse pas le côté rouge
c'est que ça peut encore se tenir et
maxime et coutts et il est gérable de
maxime normal coûte franchement non je
ne parle pas comme ça de joueurs
la classe de diglee rennes qui ont plus
de 2800 et l'autre mais là les derniers
coups il a fait absolument n'importe
quoi 1
je crois qu'on peut le dire dépi la
structure noire s'est stabilisée avec
apsys la dame noire est devenue très
active en d1 cavaillé g5 et le nude très
actifs alors les blancs restent mieux
évidemment ou un échec
qu'est ce que c'est perpète ou pas ici
m23 les trois dames eu un choc alors là
tu te fais maths et 1 h 4 donc tu dois
les anges et 4 parce qu'il n'ya pas
échec perpétuelle ici dan g13 f4 et
damages deux essais chacun habituel
walcott dames 7 et sur dam des trois tu
prends les deux tout simplement et sa
maxime va le calculer est le roi ne
pouvait pas monter en d5 alors à temps
il n'a pas joué ça il ajouta demeure
malheureusement
ah non mais cela dit cela dit je pense
que maintenant sa position est tout à
fait rien tout à fait raisonnable bon il
est moins bien mais là il menace son nul
tout de suite avec kf3 mais c'est
dommage de ne pas l'avoir vu aussitôt
ben écoute ça serait quand même un qu'on
nous dit dans le chatt goana a perdu son
avantage mais on prendrait nul on
prendrait un sur deux sur les échiquiers
danaé et et et maxime et essayer après
d'aller réaliser avec notre buteur
providentiel de ce qu'il ya des maps est
absolument mellala nul n'est pas encore
faite chez maxim
c'était presque fait en cas de cavani f3
échec et gary qui va encore lui dire
arrête de jouer tu es quoi on est
secondaire il a joué d'ailleurs très
vite
encore une fois c'est marrant mais bon
c'est quand même mieux damien que le
curateur ans en six visites du coup
ouais ouais ouais mais je pense que je
pense que gary va lui dire que kovalev
trois échecs c'est une tactique pour les
enfants et qu'il aurait dû le voir
ouais j'aurais dû le voir il aurait dû
le voir alors attends je retente le
geste technique à
alors d'amener cinq échecs a été joué je
vais voir si ça si ça marche cette fois
ci mais un hameau gichuki en train de
mal jouer cette finale avaient changé
dans ses seins qu'elle est moins bien
maintenant bon c'est pas trop grave mais
elle est moins bien ouais ça tu pense
qu'elle va la tenir
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas juuju une
très bonne joueuse technique un jeu pas
très confiant je ne comprends pas trop
l'idée de ce coût d'un prince et 5
paraissait pas nécessaire de tout alors
qu'on a et voit juste pour aller
corroborer ses dires français 5 et elle
est là ont une très belle structure de
pions leroy qui avance bon c'est pas
assez sans doute pas dramatique mais bon
des risques des risques pas nécessaire
alors que alors que duda et matelas
complètement effet voilà je crois que la
jauge doit être voilà la jauge est très
très blanche comme comme vous voyez
soulevées sur la gauche a atteint
presque la fin la fin de la huitième
rang j'ai effectivement cavalli ou 4
tout simplement ou un échange préalable
angers 6 l'arrivée d'un cabas des
options prend en pions prendrait six
pions projet 6 par exemple cavaliers ou
4 je vois pas comment les noirs vont
s'en sortir
wipe 6 peut-être revient à f4 tout
simplement ou d'un match 3 ça paraît
compliqué ça paraît très compliqué lâche
4,8 ou htc et dame prend dame
bon c'est une tactique farmine parmi
tant d'autres mi temps d'autrefois f6
échec un échec à la découverte on
appelle ça et en plus il a
il lui reste quatorze minutes contre
nous et là c'est la catastrophe
je pense que gary est en train de perdre
ses cheveux sur certaines des parties
alors on essaie de se rassurer en allant
voir les van leeuwen qui qui a solidifié
sur y avait eu 4 tout à l'heure on
disait donc il a solidifié sur celui dit
fier la case ou quatre il fait tout
raffin est sûre d'un grand dessein qui
veut jouer une finale alors il veut
échanger l'imaginent et jouer tour c'est
cet échec par exemple les prendre en
bessette
c'est intéressant le roi et poupées des
possibilités d'aller chercher le pion à
aussi de jouer tout raid 6 pour aller
chercher le pion aux os 6
enfin l'équipe de chine serait pas être
un mais à l'école impressionnante de de
solidité un petit maurice ont très très
très très fort alors même si aimer ce
que vous allez mon maximum
maintenant c'est foutu ma deuxième pion
le fourbe et 8 tient tout il va pouvoir
s'en vouloir d'avoir raté kf3 échec
c'était pas très dur il a joué il a tout
joué sur l'initiative mais le fou en
baby demain maintenant tient toute la
position même si m cinq tombes
la dame bessette tient là la kf3 le fou
baby tient à diagonale n'y a plus aucun
contre jeu et
mais plus qu'à pousser leurs pions alors
peut-être cavaliers ou quatre pour
essayer de faire cavalier g3 dernière
chance des des noirs 4 on n'y croit pas
trop je sais pas ce qui peut faire sur
quatre peut-être peut-être d'am-dam
quelque part pour pour aller chercher le
plus rage tout simplement ça c'est le
coût de l'ordinateur ça vient de couvrir
les trois et ça à l'idée de venir
prendre le curage catrice marque
ouais je pensais mais madame des quatre
tout simplement pour clouer entre
guillemets qu'avait lieu 4 à cause du
curage claude kindt rennes à la la
catastrophe
ouais alors après il vaut mieux que ça
arrive dans ce match là qui de toute
façon est mal engagée que dans un autre
mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu le même
scénario qu'on avait vécu lors de la
première journée avec ont commenté avec
fabien aycard match où finalement on n'a
jamais eu l'impression de pouvoir faire
quoi que ce soit well as et c'est
l'hécatombe
c'est l'hécatombe
bah je vois pas comment on va s'en
sortir il faut absolument à demi point
de mire à q2 avec les avec avec les
noirs mais les deux positions sont
tellement fou tu ne vois pas trop
comment ça va arriver qui ont été hier
l'une est pire que l'autre lui n'est
pire que l'autre effectivement mais vu
les tactiques l'hôtel l'autre et
technique la tactique pour le moment il
joue pareil wihongi calcules tu rêves où
il a tellement il gagna aussi ak-47 qui
est tout cas l'air de gagner ça jouait
john tout ça a l'air d'aller mieux pour
les blancs la position a l'air à peu
près autour d'eux est possible ici
pourquoi l'espère tours 2 mais moi va
prendre en dessin qui la finale deux
tours devraient permis là c'est
facilement
la raison quelque chose comme ça cette
voie là elle a gagné même un pion
évidemment les noirs sont très actifs
ici
mais bon il ne devrait pas perdre ça
joue pas de ce côté-là locaux évidemment
une victoire de li veulent absolument et
devant il nous faut un miracle
ouais c'est la condition sinequanone de
d'un exploit
absolument c'est flou assume cette
maîtrise des chinois dans tous les
matchs alors que mouvement ils sont voir
qu'ils ont la meilleure équipe mais bon
pas de grand chose sur le papier quand
même on n'est pas de grand chose
pas grand chose mais sur sur l'échiquier
sur l'échiquier
il ya une grosse différence un way point
f8 qui menace un échec qui perpétuel
avec la tour des 5 avec tourner autour
des 2 donc tes vannes qui joue autour
d'eux pour éviter ça et quelle finale
deux tours supérieur et de l'activité
ils menacent tourbe et 6 qui gagnent à
point il est fort 1 s'élève à noyon il
est fort ce devon alors voyons maxime
est ce qu'ils trouvent quelques se
trouvent quelques chances pour se sortir
d'un a déjà eu l'occasion de de
l'affronter en partie officielle et les
vannes et pour un f3 qu'est ce que ce
qui s'est passé
5 royal dans les veines j'ai jamais joué
niang liedson en partie officielle ah
oui c'est incroyable il ya il est allé à
ce piège qui va arriver
eh ben c'est pas fini ce match qu'est ce
que ce fou et le faire en d2 bourgoin
pas à temps qu'est ce qui s'est passé le
foule était parfait et il a rendu le
pion à deux déjà sans raison à la kdf 5
mai à f/5 c'était peut-être pas si ça
c'était l'idée est maintenant cavalier
prendre froid c'est fort puisque sur
france 3 y aurait dame âgée trois
matches ouais alors qu'elle est
franchement il va pas prendre le
cavalier donc c'est pas si et précaires
en h3 même
vraie grosse menace mais j'imagine qu'au
minimum cavaliers avec quatre nuls au
coup suivant la maxime qui va s'en
sortir mérite pas un problème et je vais
et madame prend des 2 et la finale de
demain il va fermer ta meuf 4110
flottant et ouais alors là c'est
incroyable ce fou qui était tellement
génial sur cette diagonale est ce
qu'avec le fonds en belgique y avait
jamais de cavale et prend h3 il y aura
toujours voix reprend et ben écoute
c'est jouer écouter pour l'incroyable
cette partie sortir et ding yifan ferait
bien de faire nul assez rapidement parce
que attention à lui pourra aussi se
faire mater ici écoute ça y est le match
est loin d'être perdue à présent petty
mandat me prends des deux mais là ça va
fermer après h3 je pense qu'il va jouer
avec une petite pression sur le plan h 4
mai khalil a complètement gâché un dab
bank a un bec à tout d'un bien ou d'un
des quatre n'importe quel coup du
protège le pion à tout ça c'est la
grosse nouvelle donc tout va se décider
ce que je propose c'est qu'on fitch et
des vols
on va se mettre en cache et devon et on
va aller voir notre buteur notre buteur
nous sauver ce match une nouvelle fois
une nouvelle foire aux vins le buteur
qui va venir qui va venir mettre tout le
monde d'accord et il a bien raison
on voit d'où deux sur la caméra j'ai vu
passer vite facebook assurent un fervent
sur un autre écran sur dix morts et 12
accueillir content de lui et pourtant
très heureux de tous tant mieux ainsi
leur en a toujours eu
voilà les vins notre notre star qui est
sorti de sa discothèque
oui il fait encore jour zoom pas besoin
de la lumière bleue j'ai ouvert les
volets les jours ils devaient faire jour
aussi un final on frise et 10 de frais
nuit alors peut-être que peut-être que
pour la deuxième partie et on va voir
bon allez on y garde si garfinkel 8 dans
le chat un petit peu bizarre les erreurs
à 6 voilà alors
oui à pitre sur internet voilà on a pas
on n'a pas la même le même niveau de jeu
que dans un tournoi des candidats mais
quelque part moi personnellement c'est
ce qui me plaît plus à suivre
voilà je laime les échecs comme comme un
sport et donc voilà j'aime j'aime voir
des erreurs et comment les joueurs
comment les joueurs en profitent
comment les joueurs sans essayer de
retourner des positions compliquées ce
genre de choses ça m'intéresse beaucoup
plus que de voir une une partie parfaite
comme parce que finalement les parties
parfaites on peut les on peut les voir à
la maison en travaillant avec un
ordinateur tout ça donc finalement c'est
la pratique qui est intéressant et avec
peu aussi peu de temps à la pendule
effectivement on va qu'on voit des
erreurs mais à mon sens c'est pas grave
du tout cela elle va pas être facile
ouais j'aime pas trop ce qu'a fait des
vannes là il a donné l'activité rendu
l'activité en france et que surtout
rejet 2 pour les protéger le pion il y
aurait même acheté à l'heure est à 32
points soit il a oublié les bonnes parce
que je pense qu'il a la meilleur
avantage que ça donc police fighter a
perdu pour ceux qui ne pour ceux qui ne
voient que le vrai nom de jean
christophe d'apparaître on l'appelle
police fighter c'est pas une moquerie
c'est son pseudo tout simplement sur
chaque point comme oui j'ai simple ce
qui me fait marrer à chaque fois à cinq
jeux d'eau qui lui va bien
on ne peut pas maxima on peut pas dire
que ça lui va bien
maxime et anne à qui on fait nul donc
c'est la dernière partie est donc on
faisait pas des blagues
quand on vous disait que c'était
maintenant le joueur providentiel qui
devait aller gagner la partie pour nous
sauver et 20 c'est le cas il ya 1 0 pour
pour la chine vous pouvez voir à gauche
de votre écran et il reste plus que les
bornes aronian ouais mais qui
malheureusement a gâché son avantage oui
malheureusement un peu gâchée davantage
alors un petit point score sur les
autres matchs avec l'inde qui mène un et
demi à 0,5 contre le reste du monde
grâce à une victoire d'ari krishna sur
une jolie petite tactique à la fin j'ai
l'impression est pour l'instant
seulement une nulle entre les etats-unis
et la russie donc encore donc un match
où ils restent tout à jouer et encore et
encore tout à faire ça nous arrangerait
peut-être que la russie gagne alors la
russie donc gorillaz qui n'a est mieux
quand même au dernier expliquait contre
irina couche et cariat qui n'est mieux
aussi un peu mieux voir nettement mieux
contre wesley so et nepomniachi est
moins bien contre nakamura mais voilà
une finale deux tours avec des chances
de bonnes chances de nul incroyable
grâce à finale hier entre yade
nepomniachi et et maxime vachier lagrave
lorsque j'ai trouvé encore plus
incroyable c'est la défaite de
nepomniachi en quinze coups seulement
contre contre la norme dans une position
très théorique n'est pas venu hachey ya
effectivement qui a pas eu une bonne
journée et incroyable finale où maxime a
pas réussi à trouver le chemin mais je
veux mais j'ai de mes chevaux regarder
la partie et je voyais que l'ordinateur
disait que c'était très très facile pour
maxime et moi je lui dis mais ça me
paraît pas si simple quand même et
finalement un moment donné c'est devenu
nul et maxime l'a torturé jusqu'à
jusqu'à épuisement et il a pris le point
il a pris deux points très importants en
vue de la suite de la compétition un
point très important
malheureusement là les bonnes well even
là les deux pions vont avoir du mal à
être poussé à temps il veut il veut une
idée simple et de tourbe et 7 à 7 b 6
tours b 8 à huit il a quand même un
plomb alors il a il a un plan le
problème c'est que l'on est un peu
faible mais à tours 2 tient bien et
autres avantages ou
2 contre 30 secondes ça on commence à
avoir l'habitude d'un genre commence à
avoir l'habitude contre contre 14
secondes ne sais pas j'étais pas là jour
il va faire comment alors tourbe et 7 à
7 allez vas-y vas-y les bonnes montrer
qui est le patron
ce qui réfléchit à tour j'ai eu deux ici
jeudi une autre option mais le point de
lectoure j'ai 2 h 3 tours projet si son
nom vous lui en veut pas en fait enlever
cette touriste branger parce qu'après le
roi noir de roi blanc bien trop faible
le roi doit partir n'importe où mais là
risquons mais ce qui peut calculer un je
dis pas que ça marche à fond là tu te
fais maths et un tour b1 tourbe et deux
tués par toi
ouais donc justement c'est pour ça qu'il
faut absolument garde de cette tour sur
la seconde rangée et il a fait tout bct
à 7
et là ils forcent les noirs être précis
dans leur quête d'un échec perpétuelle
parce que si les noirs n'arrive pas n'y
arrive pas les plans concernant
ils ont trois coups pour pour créer un
réseau de faire péter noir mais faut
faire gaffe en sur des rois g2 peu
commence aussi à avoir des échecs avec
l'eau tour qui revient mettre des échecs
que c'est une avec 10 secondes à la
pendule elle est très dur à jouer -
est-ce que tu fais tourner deux joué
tour a je crois bien vu bien vu menace
tour à tour à deux avec échec
perpétuelle instantané ça c'est très
bien joué de la part de loyer mais c'est
peut-être la variante qui ça ça fait mal
bien défendu en fallait trouver tous
âges froid va aller le trouver toi je
crois c'est vraiment bien joué on voit
les vrais à la caméra qui qui donne tout
ce qu'il a il donne tout ce qui donne
mais là alors est-ce qu'il peut revenir
en e2 et surtour g3 faire autre chose
mais non je crois pas et obligé
d'interposer la tour c'est énorme
défense un de bruit avec 10 secondes à
la pendule comme ça tu as trouvé tour
j'ai trois tours h3c
place quand même de quoi de quoi
paniquer dans cette finale il ya
certainement encore de quoi paniquer
peut-être signer 23 une bonne façon de
le poser des problèmes mais j'ai
l'impression voilà que le roi blanc est
trop faible
ouais on n'arrive pas j'essaye de
chercher aussi un pendant que pendant
que tu parles j'essaie de me projeter
sur des coups mais je ne vois rien et
toi j'ai pensé à l'évasion tour est fait
pour ramener l'autre tour mais le
problème c'est que ça permettrait à
l'adversaire alors attendu tourner le
code 3,5 de jeu airways 5 et maintenant
tous points de cote sinon les blancs
perde ses seins et maintenant qu'est ce
qui se passe ce que c'est a tour à tour
g3 et tours j'ai trois rois f2 ou échec
perpétuelle la tête se cacher un les
vols tout cas il a pris le pion tour
j'ai trois joutes direct 2 bref deux
tours à l'o2 sur wild tour h2k on peut
peut jamais allé en valeur un temps à il
peut aller en d1 il peut aller en d1 et
surtour gère maintenant ils à tours 1
qu'est ce que c'est bien joué de la part
de l'evole en son tour à toi de retour
défend contre et 8 d'un mais attention à
pas su arrêter alors et wall-e piège à
l'arrêt tout reprend h4 encore très très
joli ton coin h4 on peut montrer roi
prend h4 pour acheter un échec
voilà quelques parts aux proches de le
problème c'est qu'ici on reprend pas en
h2 parce que réfléchissez bessette et la
tour ne pourraient pas arrêter les deux
pions mais on fait simplement tout
reprend à cette lettre prendre la tour
blanche et la position nuls alors au
noir revient au f4 par exemple c'est
dommage mais quelle défense du joueur
chinois encore une fois alors est ce que
tout ça a été joué oui c'est jouer tour
jusqu'à tours à froid mais il a
forcément tous furent bien forcément
tout est là il va faire tout reprend h4
parce que s'il ne fait pas il est foutu
il n'y a pas d'autre quoi
il n'y a pas d'autres coups il est déçu
à la caméra il sait qu'une nul est
synonyme de défaite pour l'équipe
européenne mais il n'a pas le choix
mme yvette obligés de il va être obligé
de la prendre ici d'un nul parce que ça
sert à rien de donner un point pour rien
non plus un tour point h4 jouer mais
mais mais voilà on apprend à se gâter a
pas de piège en plus un énorme peuvent
faire ils peuvent aller n'importe où
avec le roi pour un scot est très
logique
seul piège c'est d'aller prendre la tour
mais mais bon à ce niveau là evans qui
aura fait une belle partie à convaincre
une belle partie mais corps à ces
dommages à un moment donné quand même
avec un quart d'heure contre montre
aussi peu de contre quelques secondes
c'est dommage de d'avoir laissé les
noirs s'en sortir aussi bien donc ça va
être une fête malheureusement deux ans
et demi pour la chine la chine qui est
vraiment dans une forme exceptionnelle
la salle annuler la news va être signée
d'un moment à l'autre nul leeuwen qui
propose là nul de manière sportive des
qui tua dès qu'il ya eu plus et qui a
plus de jeu les vols qui propose tout de
suite c'est aussi c'est quand même sympa
hein
ouais là c'est bon il y avait vraiment
plus rien à jouer alors il aurait pu
aller jusqu'à 3 contre 3 mais bon
pourquoi perdre de l'énergie
quel dommage effectivement sa santé le 2
partout alors quel raté de digby rennes
qui est vraiment en forme en ce moment
mais qui n'est pas en forme alors je
propose qu'on aille voir l'équipe le
match nous intéresse le plus entre les
russes et les américains et des pommiers
achi qui va peut-être enchaîné 1 0 sur 3
effectivement des pommes merci carrière
foutu contre nakamura une finale deux
tours avec égalité matérielle mais c'est
ses pions double équivalent qu'un pion
en fait finalement
bref 5 et la coordination des psd pierre
blanche est parfaite et la tour qui aura
plus de 4 sur les sixièmes wave525 à
tour pu avoir de casse c'est
ouais ouais 53.5 quand même mais je
pense dès 5h et à faire grève six échecs
on va pousser le pion à eux
ouais et effectivement on bat même s'il
ya deux clans chacun on voit bien que
l'opinion que les pions des noirs ne
servent à rien donc naka qui devrait
faire très très mal
aïe année à la russie la russie qui peut
être éliminé à la suite de ce match je
pense qu'on pourra on pourra le dire et
à wayne carr yakine qui a de moins en
moins davantage contrôler wesley so donc
ça sent une victoire de la russie
effectivement de deux des états unis à
des états unis par des états unis qui
donnerait
alors je vais remettre un petit point
sur les classements pour que tout le
monde l'ait bien en tête mais la chine
qui vient de battre l'europe qui à 13
points de la chine
comme on le disait avant était plus ou
moins déjà qualifié mais
mathématiquement qualifiés maintenant
c'est fait et la russie qui se
retrouveraient à trois journées trois
matches de la fin avec deux victoires de
moins que l'europe et les états unis en
sachant que ces deux équipes vont
s'affronter
j'ai envie de dire en cas de défaite ça
on sera finie aussi des espoirs russes
dans cette compétition romain
effectivement et donc tout va se jouer
contre les états unis
tout va je compte les états unis en
espérant un match aussi propre que que
celui d'avant-hier ça va être tendu un
ça va être tendu de chez tendu et on
demande c'est quoi tim roe cetim reste
du monde reste of the world en anglais
reste du monde
en traduction ça ça à faire nuance je
propose qu'on suive du coup à la finale
à ça va un petit peu mieux parce qu'à la
place d'un pion pas c'est eux qui
faisait dam des blancs se retrouve avec
un pion h qui est bloqué par le roi
adverse ont toujours une finale mauvaise
là les normes ne peuvent pas échanger
les tours par exemple et prendre le pion
à chaque parce que les le roi blanc avec
trop rapidement de l'autre côté ramasse
tout est le pion bva allait ensuite adam
donc les noirs doivent garder la tour et
on voit la tour 5 qui est parfaitement
placé qui couple qui défend des saints
qui défend le 5 h 5 qui découpent la
cinquième ranger qui cobos ch'tis lors
le roi noir et le roi blanc qui va qui
va maintenant c'est au filet de l'autre
côté c'est à dire si les noirs ici
autour des 4 par exemple - férois aussi
c'est ensuite on va faire tour des 5 3
des 6 sont la socli des peuples alors on
va peut-être avoir du mal à se faufiler
après ouais ça que ça se serait on va
dire ça paraît de la seule défense mam
moment donné a abandonné on va quand
même lâché les chevaux et on va partir
avec la tour aller chercher par exemple
larroy 17 et puis on va les faire tomber
si tour des six échecs
non je pensais pas que ça passe mais
aussi ses 5
on s'est plutôt roi 17 quand la tour
étant des cinq puis tour des six les
tours b 6 voilà on améliore au maximum
les pièces avant de jouer avant d'aller
chercher les pions voilà on a rapproché
le roi au maximum
et là le roi noir est trop loin pour la
déco la défense voilà c'est ce qu'on
appelait une position du sénat qui va
arriver
voilà d'ici quelques courts et gagner
encore le roi noir actuellement moins
que celle du sénat ^ ^ 2 et là il a fait
trois sets avant alors c'est encore pire
parce que il fait encore plus tôt ouais
hélas hélas mais non plus facile alors
du coup il va faire alors l'inde qui a
des gens qui a déjà gagné puisque
hollande a gagné et même si la partie
firouz à contre-visite se retourne ça va
faire de lui un ennemi pour pour les
indiens pour les indiens aux mille au
pire pour eux est donc il faut que
cariat qu'il réussisse à gagner cette
finale contre us l'eso ça paraît pas
exactement est en train de se produire
c'est une grosse déception encore pour
l'équipe de russie romain être éliminés
après après cette ronde s'est passé pas
si voilà qu'on attend l'équipe de russie
1 parce que alors on peut dire après que
l'europe sait c'est pas un seul pays
c'est une région du monde mais bon là
les états unis et la chine sont des pays
où effectivement il effectivement qui
est capitaine de l'équipe de russie
d'heure parce que c'est amusant d'avoir
ramené capitaine de l'équipe vendent
si j'ai bien lu si j'ai bien lu les
influents ils ont remis un nom de
capitaine je crois et cramique
consultants or j'ai pas trop a contrario
nettement hockey et qui est capitaine de
l'équipe de russie s'est motivé of war
d'accord motivé est aussi un aussi
présent à chaque fois avec l'équipe de
russie aux olympiades et c'est un choix
logique oui c'est vrai l'équipe de
russie qui
et qui n'a pas de faiblesse mais le
problème n'est pas menacée c'est que
c'est tout ou rien et un dépôt minatchy
qui la part de quillan rapide on aurait
pu attendre un score monumental
finalement perdre toutes ses parties
alors forcément y arriver tout les grand
danger sur un match en quatre parties
voilà quand notre meilleur camp de
meilleur joueur est hors de forme et
perd toutes ses parties bah voilà après
fabien proposer une stratégie un peu
différente un fabien qui nous proposait
de m yakari acquis deux premiers
échiquiers
et en cas de méforme de nepomniachi de
pouvoir le sortir comme ça il m'était
carrés à qui nos premiers pour aller
prendre des nuls et derrière il disait
qu deux ou trois sites avaient artemiev
et et andré qui nous artemiev et matelas
coffre ou vite yougov où il y en a un
pour le troisième et fichiers ou great
choukoud suite l'air si tu veux sortir
aussi un voyage imagine qu'ils ont voulu
mettre les jeunes ados boeuf est pas là
c'est bizarre ouais enfin en tout cas tu
pouvais faire une stratégie où tu
prenais - le risque d'un dépôt me achi
en mettant cariat qui n'ont bloqueurs en
premier et alors après nepomniachi est
tellement fort en ce moment qu'ils se
sont dit on va mettre aux premiers âges
et peut-être que cardiac kids qui a
quand même perdu presque 100 points elo
peut-être que lui a dit à son capitaine
écoute je ne la sens pas du tout premier
à chiquer contre contre les meilleurs du
comment le joug ces derniers mois c'est
possible aussi un faux c'est pas faux
c'est pas faux mais en tout cas car
yakine c'est ça c'est tout ou rien et
quand c'est rien by little j écoutais y
coûte la compétition c'est assez
difficile pour un monde meilleur
quand c'est rien c'est rien
effectivement je me rappelle d'un
championnat d'europe individuel ou
nepomniachi jouets mais vraiment à la
table je sais pas me jouer 13,5 en tout
absent enfin on le voyait même plus quoi
la fin de la première journée
donc au bout de neuf rondes et à la fin
la remise des prix tout à coup je le
vois monter sur la troisième marche du
podium jeudi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il me bat g
aujourd'hui j'ai gagné les neuf quoi
donc voilà il y avait complètement
inversé le score
il avait rejoint pratiquement
pratiquement à la tête du tournoi en
live il avait terminé troisième donc
tout ou rien c'est tout ou rien c'est
tout rien mais c'est vrai que une équipe
avec alors qu'une chauve c'est vrai
qu'il n'a pas été pris la veille 1 fois
aux olympiades mais c'est vrai qu'un
joueur comme cris tout camarade iman
qu'un bon c'est pas prouvée la pas jouer
peut-être qu'il n'a pas envie jouer sur
internet où elle n'a pas non plus joué
le magnus invitationnal alexander on
connaît pas vraiment la maison tu dis il
n'a pas été pris en équipe de russie où
il a refusé
est ce qu'on est sûr qu'il n'a pas été
sélectionné ouais il n'a pas été bien
d'accord blacks devaient savoir ça se
fabrique un peu spécial
quel choc un peu spécial c'est pas
forcément la personne la plus diplomate
sur terre oui on a vu ça à l'ancienne
nous ça nous amuse à pâques comment il
le vit comme ils le vivent en équipe en
interne je sais pas tag life
ouais c'est ça c'est eric lux est un peu
spécial donc après il peut aussi avoir
des raisons pour lesquelles ils sont ils
soient ils soient pas prises sept pour
l'ambiance des qui peut-être aurions pu
viser la dernière fois la région c'était
plutôt qu'il met une équipe de jeunes
les doubles pour la première fois émis
affection etc
ouais c'est sûr
donc là ouais cette partie qui va faire
une carrière qui ne peut pas tenter avec
les norias rien à faire non en fait je
pense que c'est même wesley qui
réfléchit à voir s'il peut s'il la joue
et jouer sans risque
c'est vrai que vu à quel point c'est
serré entre les l'europe et les états
unis un point de colle avérage ici n'est
pas n'est pas à simplement anecdotique
un nom absolument donc tu vois c'est
qu'il ya qui a priori la joue pour
gagner cette finale il a un plan de plus
il aurait pu faire tout reprendre et 4
et où les qui déferle hull mais la joue
pour gagner
effectivement il a dû avoir la consigne
ils ont dû avoir la consigne s'ils
peuvent aller chercher le goal avérage
il faut quand même faire attention parce
que
les laurentins plongée mais bon des clés
noires pousse le plonger le roi blanc
recolle je pense quand même que je pense
que ça très vite on gaspille rien faire
4.2 tous échange ils payent bien même
pas avec le roi prochain les partis et
la russie on peut le dire et est éliminé
absolument
trois projets 63.5 tout s'échange
peut-être qu'ils vont aller jusqu'à 3
contre roy pour les spectateurs
nice et les grillades marla et c'est
fait c'est fait romain alors donc ça
veut dire la chine ont fait un de ces
régimes et la chine qui pas l'europe
l'inde qui par le reste du monde les usa
qui bat de la russie est donc au
classement ça nous fait la chine qui
caracole en tête avec 13 points devant
les usa qui apparemment un meilleur goal
avérage que nous mais ça on jette un
oeil ce soir c'est un peu tôt en goal
avérage mais c'est pas forcément la
bonne nouvelle est derrière les trois
équipes qui vont se battre pour la
quatrième place la russie l'inde et le
reste du monde
absolument absolument donc on va voir
vivement ce match contre contre les
états unis qui va décider de tout thomas
triste comme tout comme on disait pour
la russie qui maintenant va s'ennuyer un
petit peu puisque puisqu'il joue même
plus vraiment pour le podium ce qui est
un petit peu inhabituel pour l'équipe de
russie
mais le pire pour eux c'est qu'ils ont
joués en plus dans les matchs retour ils
ont déjà joué contre l'europe et contre
les états unis n'ont même plus l'espoir
d'avoir un
un duel pour rattraper voire l'équipe as
tu du monde qui qui galère ils sont
forts pourtant aussi mais bon ils sont
quand même sont quand même en dessous et
l'inde
bah nan tu vois s'il avait battu
l'europe le fameux match qu'on avait
commenté ensemble ils ont réussi ce
l'europe s'est t il pas encore dedans et
la russie aussi d'ailleurs
absolument l'inde qui a manqué un peu de
réussite on nous dit oui que que visiter
toujours à zéro point
aïe aïe aïe aïe bini qui a perdu cette
partie contre les vannes qu'il a encore
été bien et a perdu 1 way était bien
content chez rhodia a perdu la partie
et donc il à 0 sur sur cinq noms en
visite à un ami a tenu compte car
rhône-alpes 120 quand même là il a
peut-être ya peut-être un demi sur cinq
mais plus encore il fut un demi sur cinq
ouais c'est quand même bâlois non c'est
pas génial surtout que c'est un joueur
qui a les qualités un surtout en rapide
de rivaliser au deuxième et chic y est
mais voilà quand tu passes à travers sa
des joueurs de ce calibre robin c'est
compliqué de chez compliqué élevé les
bornes 5 sur 5 non non il a fait des
vins vient de faire nul donc et van
leeuwen avait perdu la première dont
quatre et demi sur 7
oui mais après il a gagné à des parties
très importante il y avait des parties
très importante duda 50% chez nous ou
qu'à 50% mvl à 4 sur 7
voilà six nuls une victoire
il avait vient d'échapper à une défaite
pourtant aujourd'hui qui semblait
inévitable au mauvais tournoi
nepomniachi évidemment donc un point et
demi sur six rattraper un peu par les
autres russes qui ont tous des bons
scores
grosso modo les pommiers richie qui
coûte 1 comme on le disait juste avant
et à un nombre très impressionnant à
nantes 4 et demi sur 7 + 2 en ayant joué
nakamura bas en ayant joué tous les
meilleurs donc un hand
annan qui restent qui reste anondin
malgré le fait que l'on parle plus de
lui comme un possible futur challenger
de manu son nom le vois comme quelqu'un
dont voilà qui a eu son qui a eu son
temps mais quand il est quand il est là
et ben je rappelle u2 je me rappelle de
son dernier 26 tours d'ailleurs il avait
il été aussi il est aussi dans les
premiers nous en sommes nous
impressionnait donc un angle qui a
manqué qui lâche pas assez le fait
d'erreur je me fais erreur
il a quel âge 20 ans la lande il a quel
age and ondes alors pour pas dire de
bêtises je vais vérifier le chiffre
exact mais il doit bien et toi bien en
avoir une de bien être à la cinquantaine
ont alors l'idée est née en non je me
suis trompé de hand on va chercher sa
cinquante ans exactement né en 1969
c'est quand même beau 50 ans de pouvoir
jouer encore à ce niveau là c'est c'est
très impressionnant effectivement l'a
dit mercredi qu' qui à 44 30 qui a pris
sa retraite il ya déjà déjà un an
maintenant pour avoir un peu plus
maintenant de nantes qui a dit ans que
j'attends que j'arrive encore à jouer
moi je joue écoute moi j'aimerais bien
jouer comme lui j'ai pas 50 encore mais
j'aimerais bien pouvoir avoir son niveau
donc comme beaucoup de monde
ouais non mais il est incroyable ah non
il est de vitesse de calcul qui est
phénoménal je me rappelle quand j'étais
quand j'étais gamin et que je suivais
les échecs de haut niveau en rapide il
était
était incroyable déjà ouais c'est
toujours été un excellent joueur de
rapides et blitz à nantes
et puis et puis jouer assez vite aussi
en cadence temps donc finalement ces
nouveaux formats
ces nouveaux formats rapide ça la salle
arrange peut-être un petit peu je me
demande vraiment s'il n'y avait pas eu
kasparov combien d'années il aurait pu
être champion du monde à 1 à nantes
parce que vu qu'il était numéro 2
derrière gary pendant quelques années et
qu'il a eue longévité quand même
incroyable et ensuite s'il n'avait pas
eu manu sociaux oui mais tu vois il est
tombé quand même sur les deux grottes
comme on dit gates of all times
ah non dit il a quand même réussi à être
champion du monde et il a réussi à les
embêter
et il a réussi à durer dans le temps
plus que finalement absolument c'était
c'est un grand champion c'est ce que me
disait topalov toujours d'ailleurs une
dizaine inde
il faut avoir le plus grand respect
parce que lui ça a été un vrai champion
il a toujours été
voilà pour ces matches il a toujours été
qualifié à la loyale s'était pas jamais
des walt câbles ou des choses comme ça
c'était s'est qualifié il a gagné il a
gagné combien de matchs il a gagné 4
c'est ça qui est bein oui je crois bien
ré voilà donc un vrai champion du monde
n'apporte quel champion du monde un vrai
champion du monde mais lui c'était
vraiment enceinte c'est l'un des très
grands oui et puis en plus un caractère
en tout cas vu de l'extérieur
gentil sympa c'est quelqu'un de très
calme a pas car pop en fait oui
j'aimerais dire qu'il y ait un peu comme
topalov peut-être très doux ça m'amuse à
chaque fois que tu existes vale of trade
ou alors le voilà je le touche de
comparer plus tôt dans son attitude à
karpov mais doux quand même
oui d'où je veux c'est plutôt doué c'est
parce qu'il est temps que ça dans cet
âge
cet adjectif ne sais pas mais c'est
surtout quelqu'un de très sympa de très
calmes de préposés voilà avec centriste
quitté alors franchement c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui fait plaisir et il vient
souvent accompagné de sa femme je crois
non pour les tournois qui j'avais cru
lire dans une interview qui c'était
quelqu'un vraiment de très important
pour lui ouais effectivement sa femme
haruna qui a qui a su assez souvent avec
les qui managent un peu tout tout un
genre d'agents dont qui managent
indiscrétions manager s'occupe s'occupe
de gnl de gérer sa carrière
effectivement comme ça hein on ne peut
se concentrer uniquement sur son jeu
mais tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde
je pense qu'ils ont un agent qui même
maxime vachier lagrave un agent laurent
vérat oui mais que d'autres pas là je
crois que c'est danilov c'est ça 9la nay
l'offre c'est un agent et donc voilà si
si ça peut être leur femme écoute
pourquoi pas non mais c'est beau comme
ça de tu vois il ya c'est pas tout le
temps que tu as des histoires de gens tu
as qu'ils sont en couple avec leurs
femmes qui gèrent tous très bien et c
enfin c'est une belle histoire en
général à raconter quoi ils font tout
ensemble ouais c'est une belle histoire
si fini champion pilote et un mariage si
je me trompe pas un mariage un mariage
arrangé parce qu'on parle
voilà un mariage arrangé comme ça se
fait souvent en inde 2 qui se 2 qui se
sont extrêmement bien trouvé et voilà
l'année l'année l'histoire raconte en
tout cas voilà que c'est un marais que
c'est un mariage arrangé et que les deux
les deux se sont trouvé une façon ça va
pas pu être que ça aurait pas pu être
mieux quoi et c'est une belle histoire
je trouves tu vois parfois des histoires
c'était écrit dans un bouquin on y
croirait pas forcément et c'est sympa
d'or des belles histoires comme ça à
l'inde et à nantes qui est vraiment
quand tu joues en plus il est vraiment
en forme un t'as l'impression que je
donne pas la cinquantaine dont je vois
passer à la caméra ouais tiens la forme
qu'il tient la forme vichy en assurant
une bonne hygiène de vie
effectivement toute façon dans tous ces
champions de chèques ou une bonne
hygiène de vie
sinon sinon c'est impossible de tenir
plusieurs heures sur un échiquier
ouais forcément c'est compliqué en vas
tu parlais il ya deux jours de de
topalov qui qui allait marcher avec toi
le matin faisait les des grandes balades
topalov waimes bien marché il fait un
petit peu des 8
il fait pas de sport violent quand ils
voient en salle de sport il fait juste
du stepper mais voilà avec fait et fait
ce qu'il faut pour rester en forme et
comme tous les comme tous les comme tous
les meilleurs joueurs du monde à leur
carlson nuit mais pratiquer tous les
sports et un maximum maxime lui va
courir c'est son truc d'aller courir du
sport tout nous dit floby billets doux
ces chiffres c'est juste et partant lui
c'est vraiment dû cependant toujours là
c'est vrai ça me convient bien ça lui
convient bien à l'étude ne la donnent
envie de plus découvrir topalov du coup
parce que ça c'est que sur l'échiquier
son style de jeu c'est plutôt sauvage
son style de jeu et sauvage le style de
son de son agent qu'il représente aussi
d'anecdotes et assez sauvage danilov
quelqu'un d'assez voilà d' assez
agressif en général et topalov
effectivement qui comme personne est à
l'opposé de tout ça très calme très doux
très posé va prendre son café était à
salamanque on descendait dans un bar
entre deux cafés tout le monde lui taper
sur l'épaule comment tu vas wesseling et
c'est une ville très très très calme
dans la vie de tous les jours tu as déjà
eu des clash avec dana love du coup pas
du tout non non non mais moi j'ai jamais
eu de souci ça arrive et qui me font une
fois je me suis gouré 2
deux bus pour salamanque est une chose
qui m'a raccroché au nez mais raccroché
au nez du genre bon bah on t'attend à un
petit peu agacé quoi ça c'est donc
qu'elle discute mois pour pour être
inculte laisser dans quelles régions
d'espagne en andalousie
c'est en andalousie doit il fallait il
faut prendre l'avion jusqu'à jusqu'à ce
que ces magouilles de malaga sur malaga
non je suis tête entre les deux ça nous
avions jusqu'à malaga en tout cas et
ensuite il faut prendre le mieux c'était
de prendre le mieux c'était de prendre
un taxi pour aller jusqu'au centre-ville
ensuite y avait des bus assez rapide et
j'avais raté j'avais oublié là j'avais
oublier l'option taxi et moi j'avais
acheté un billet d'avis de trains de bus
pour salamanque dans l'aéroport sauf
qu'il fallait attendre deux heures que
ça parte et que le bus ensuite mettez
une heure de plus que le bus normal
depuis le centre-ville et dans les dom
mais dit on mais bon c'est le clash le
plus violent qu'on a vu où il malade
qu'est ce que tu as fait qu'est ce que
tu fais bombe à hong kong en un match de
foot en plus avec avec topalov il
m'attendait et donc il a dit bon bah du
coup tu attendras je t'attends pas parce
que il t'attend mais moi je t'attends
pas parce que le match sera fini et du
coup b série qui parle de l'espagnol oui
parle espagnol couramment d'anecdotes
aussi mais ils habitent en espagne n'ont
depuis
si c'est pas indiscret l'amidon quel
point veselin alors salle à salamanque
et il a aimé ce qu'il a déménagé il ya
pas très longtemps et méga bits et
soissons salamanque c'est pas très grand
mais voilà il habite pas loin du manoir
du centre ville mais toute façon c'est à
la menthe ou t'es pas loin du centre
ville à celle en qui la vie tu vois je
le voyais je sais pas je vous voyais
plus choisis rendre au bord de mer ou
quoi quand tu peux
il aime bien web accessible je sais
seulement que le centre-ville c'est pas
le centre-ville parisien où
ou le centre-ville barcelonais sur une
grande place sympa avec avec moins de
café et ses annonces à toi ça doit ça
doit être agréable et toi aussi du coup
tu as choisi de quitter de rencontre
était du côté d'espagne si oui moi je
suis à barcelone chez au centre de
barcelone moi j'aime bien la ville
j'aime bien que ça bouge un petit peu
ouais c'est bon ce moment ça va bouger
mais en général ça doit être très sympa
trouver mais bon ça bouge pas trop rire
un peu de monde qu'en dehors on en
profite pour pour demander des nouvelles
de l'espagne comment ça se passe c'est
un petit peu je crois que le de
confinement commencer un petit peu ici
aussi c'est à dire qu'ils les
consultations médicales sont réouvertes
par exemple voilà les consultations
générales g il ya des hôpitaux étaient
ouverts évidemment que les consultations
généralistes par exemple se faisait par
téléphone jusqu'à il ya quelques jours
et je crois que là ils ont réouvert les
cabinets par exemple donc je pense que
peu à peu ils espèrent ré ouvrir bientôt
à ouvrir un maximum de choses
et côté est côté sportif du coup on sait
pour les échecs par exemple en france
pour tous de tourner ont été annulés ou
reportés
est ce que est ce qu en espagne une
reprise des échecs est d'actualité
je ne pense pas non non je pense que le
classement les directives en europe vont
être à peu près les mêmes partout et
donc ici c'est pareil là on voit tous
les interclubs français qui ont été
annulés du coup pratique voilà le top 12
saisons blanches la n1 n2 n3 pareil et
là c'est pareil voilà la ligue catalan
il restait des rondes les rondes finales
à jouer les deux rondes finales sur la
demi finale et la finale c'était annulé
et ça absolument pas quand ça pourra
avoir lieu
et tout un circuit de tournois qui
commence normalement en mai qui termine
en septembre octobre
et oui tout va être annulé enfin voila
c'est partout pareil
et donc toi tu jouais pour pour
certaines équipes en france y joue dans
quel club dans la dans la première
vision qui s'appelle le top 12 1 si je
ne m'abuse le jeu pour bischwiller
vigiles rtl est champion de france
on est champion de france et voilà on
espérait d'être à nouveau ses taux
mais mais le top-12 n'aura pas lieu il
ya eu un vote ya quelques jours pour
savoir quelle équipe voulait tenter
d'organiser quand même le top 12 au mois
de septembre et qu'elle dit qu'il
voulait tout simplement oublié cette
saison bischwiller je crois a soutenu
l'idée de jouer au mois de septembre
mais il ya quand même eu 8 8 votes
contre quatre pour pour l'annulation
général et est ce que tu peux nous
raconter un petit peu comment ça se
passe ces championnats par équipes en
interclubs
comment se déroulent les matches est ce
que c'est un format comme on a là pour
pour cette compétition sait où c'est
différent alors c'est un petit peu un
format comme ça à part qu'il ya plus
d'échiquier l'auto douce et 8 échiquier
et aussi l'obligation d'une dune
féminine d'une joueuse
donc voilà le top 12
ce sont cinq joueurs français trois
joueurs étrangers est une joueuse
française par équipes
donc voilà huit échiquier 12 équipes et
c'est un tournoi fermé donc toutes les
équipes se rencontrent comme dans le
coma la nationscup mais ne se rend
compte qu'une seule fois donc voilà
c'est un double c'est un double ronde
puisque chaque équipe se rencontrent
deux fois et le top-12 c'est un voilà
c'est un geste c'est un aller simple
voilà douze équipes 11 matchs est ce
l'équipe et l'équipe qui marque le plus
de points sur les onze matches et chant
est sacrée championne de france et a du
coup c'est une cadence tulon gars on est
bien d'accord les matchs durent c'est un
mas c'est une compétition au cadencement
est effectivement une compétition qui
dure onze jours donc une partie par jour
avec une cadence lente donc du genre
1h40 tus 30 secondes par coup avec un
rajout de temps de 40 minutes ou de 30
minutes au 40e coup donc des partis qui
peuvent durer parfois cinq six heures
c'est ça se ressent les échecs classique
évidemment mais plus ça va plus on
migrants aujourd'hui vers percée cadence
rapide passe pas seulement parce que
parce qu'on est confiné que ça joue sur
internet mais aussi parce que c'est ce
que les médias demandent c'est ce que
les gens pour la plupart ont envie de
voir
et plus ça va plus on a pu en at on eu
rapide 1 le grand duché ce tour
le déguste un tour mag c'est un circuit
de tournois k danse classique et puis
maintenant ça faisait plus de plus 2
tournera vite que de rider le tournoi
non même le grand prix fidh maintenant
ils ont une fille y fonder un système
par élimination pour qu'un jour sur
trois on est des rapides et des beats
toi à titre personnel en tant que joueur
tu préfères le rapide ou le classique
moi je suis pour plutôt une diminution
des cadences 1 comme je te dis je suis
pour un format qui puisse qui puisse
intéresser les gens qui donnent déjà qui
donne le temps aux gens de pouvoir
suivre éventuellement et journée d'échec
parce qu'une partie qui dure cinq heures
six heures voilà c'est compliqué à toi
par exemple j'adore regarder le tennis
le foot même si les matches et un match
de foot duré 6 heures est ce que je le
regarderai tu vois je sais pas donc
voilà si je cours je suis pour cette
diminution des cadences au détriment
malheureusement de la qualité de jeu
mais voilà je préfère je préfère voir
des erreurs je sais que commettrait
autant que autant que les autres voilà
c'est agaçant quand on est joueur
d'échecs de faire une erreur par manque
de temps ou une grosse gaffe et de
perdre une partie gagnante mais ses
parades
je suis pour cet aspect sportif du jeu
d'échecs
voilà matériel et pour le spectacle t
pour tes pour la médiatisation du jeu
pour le spectacle et pour absolument
démocratisation voilà je suis pour qu'on
se rapproche d'un format qui peut
attirer un maximum de gens on a déjà ces
difficultés les échecs par rapport à
n'importe quel autre sport c'est c'est
vraiment notre difficulté c'est que
pratiquement n'importe quel sport
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais qui n'en a
jamais entendu parler peut le regarder
par exemple quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
entendu parler de ping-pong qui n'a
jamais entendu parler de foot
qui n'a jamais entendu parler de tennis
il pu regarder un match et comprendre ce
qui se passe aux échecs il faut quand
même connaître les règles de base
et voilà apprendre des règles des échecs
ça prend quand même une ou deux heures
et s'est un temps voilà c'est quelque
chose que tout le monde n'a pas fait et
voilà donc si on veut peu à peu qui est
de plus en plus de monde qui regarde les
échecs il faut au moins que le format
soit attractif que les gens disent ah
tiens ça a l'air sympa de voir ces voir
ses joueurs qui jouent les parties comme
ça en dix minutes devaient des choses
voilà j'ai aussi compliqué des coûts qui
songe aussi rapidement j'aimerais bien
comprendre ce qui se passe et c'est
peut-être à poussera les gens plus à
apprendre les règles
voilà elle se diriger vers vers les
échecs et puis les voilà par les gamins
ont besoin d'un défouloir aussi donc
volé pourquoi les parents mettent leurs
gamins au tennis au foot parce que parce
qu'il faut se défouler physiquement
alors c'est vrai qu aux échelles quelle
que soit la cadence ça sera jamais la
même chose mais déjà si on arrive à
donner une image plus sportive plus fan
des échecs
je pense que ça attirera un peu plus de
monde d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
rappeler que tu as été classé dans le
top 50 mondial et que même si les les
commentaires sont nés c'est de faire
quelque chose d'assez accessible 1 pour
le plus grand nombre même si forcément
quand on suit un match a toujours des
moments un peu compliqué où on s'emballe
pas ce que parce que voilà les échecs ce
si un jeu un jeu complexe on essaye au
maximum d'être accessible mais voilà
romain qui même si dans le commentaire
il tente et il a bien raison de
d'expliquer au maximum et d'être le plus
simpliste possible c'est quand même un
joueur de très haut niveau comme on a
déjà parlé il ya deux jours dont un père
parle et là tout à l'heure tu as quand
même été le seconde entre kim et le
coach de topalov était un joueur du
premier plan mondial romain du premier
plan mondial ne s'est pas de premier
plan français peut-être on va dire ouais
nationale en tout cas ça on peut on peut
le dire sans sans faire injure à aucun
autre joueur n'a été champion de france
désirait j'étais champion de france
walchi voilà numéro trou numéro je sais
pas si aujourd'hui j'ai toujours pas
vérifié depuis des années je sais pas si
le film héros trois ou quatre français
mais bon tu tournes dans ces eaux là
quoi voilà trois quatre cinq parfois
chéri des rares joueurs violence et à
avoir dépassé la barre mythique de 2700
lots ouais ouais
ce qui est quand même
qui est quand même quelque chose fait de
sachant que voilà les deux meilleurs
français au jour 2 au jour d'aujourd'hui
même si l'autre jour on m'a dit
d'arrêter d'envoyer expression maxime
vachier lagrave qui est bien sûr
intouchable et etienne qui est quand
même aussi relativement à touches a b
tienne c'est quelqu'un qui n'occulte
sûrs et chicken qui fait que voilà même
en ces temps reconverti comme entraîneur
de maxime reste comme joueur très
clairement le deuxième meilleur joueur
français etienne c'est quand même vrai
c'est du très solide 1 ils te disent que
tu es jérôme rothen à william maclean
lagarde kessy qui est devant moi ou
alors je suis numéro 4 français
un numéro 4 ils ont vérifié qu'aucun
euro 5 d'ailleurs si laurent et devant
mes choix je suis devant laurent cette
façon ça tournant c'est à peu près où
joue à quelques points près d'un mois à
l'autre
maxime lagarde qui est champion de
france en titre qui a gagné justement au
final contre laurent cette année se
confirmait dans le chat c'est laurent
qui est numéro 5
ouais et d'ailleurs les olympiades
d'échecs
ils sont froids ils sont déjà annulés ou
vont être annulées elles sont déjà
annulé un certain pas annulée elle sont
repoussées à 2021 donc c'est à dire
qu'en principe en 2021 on devrait avoir
deux compétitions de l'équipe de france
les olympiades donc les jeux olympiques
des échecs et le championnat d'europe
puisque normalement ces acteurs nanan
sur deux les olympiades les années
paires et les championnats d'europe les
années impaires
donc là à priori avec les olympiades
repoussé on devrait avoir les deux la
même année elle sympa ça pour pour les
joueurs j'imagine alors sympa pour les
joueurs après est-ce que ça va être
facile a budgété pour une fédération
surtout afin qu un virus à ces ravageurs
voilà espérons que
espérant qu'elle puisse faire participer
tous les joueurs c'est vrai que c'est un
temps difficiles j'imagine pour les voir
professionnelle puisque comme comme pour
tous les sports un bon il ya quelques
compétitions sur internet comme vous
pouvez en suivre à présent mais ça reste
quand même il ya beaucoup moins de
compétition sur internet aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y en avait deux prévus en réel
absolument suivre normalement
normalement de compétition au réel il y
en a toujours plusieurs simultanément
dans tous les pays du monde
hélas là du coup il ya peu de il ya peu
de tournois donc ça permet d'avoir ça
permet que la toile médiatiques soient
concentrés sur le tournage du moment et
là on ce moment c'est la nationscup
nationscup qui j'espère roman est une
compétition qui va s'inscrire dans la
durée parce que je trouve que c'est
c'est quelque chose qui manquait un
petit peu aux échecs
c'est une belle idée m c'est super et
puis alors là se fait sur internet mais
alors pourquoi pas là car en vrai aussi
à oui oui complètement complètement on
est 100 % d'accord je suis 100% d'accord
avec tes paroles servons quelque chose
qui pourrait s'inscrire dans le
calendrier peut-être au lieu de ce
championnat du monde des équipes qui je
trouve c'est un petit peu double emploi
avec les olympiades à titre personnel
ouais c'est vrai qu'on a eu c'est vrai
que ce championnat du monde par équipe
et pas oui le débit n'est pas très très
médiatisée en plus je trouve qu'on
compare aux olympiades enfin c'est vrai
que les eaux là on a c'est vrai que
c'est bizarre d'avoir la davar d'avoir
cessé olympique had qui sont un
championnat du monde par équipe en fait
et plus et le championnat du monde par
équipes 1 j'ai offert un peu double
emploi s'est pas trop à quoi il sert
ouais ouais et finalement d'accord il
pourrait être remplacé par par cette
coupe des nations qui finalement elle a
un vrai un vrai intérêt prouve en tout
cas est différente
alors après ce qu'on peu ce qu'on
pouvait arriver à diviser l'équipe
européenne en plusieurs équipes où
est-ce qu'on garde si la team europe je
sais je sais pas si c'est une chose à
laquelle ils réfléchiront ou pas il
aurait pu faire une petit
amérique a mon avis tu vois un petit peu
parce que pourquoi pas ajoutez le canada
même s'il n'aurait pas apporté de
joueurs c'est pour ça qu'ils ont appelée
team usa et mais en soi ça aurait pu
être plus par par région ouais après ils
réfléchiront là c'était une première
tentative et c'est vrai que ça n'aurait
pas changé grand chose en terme d'équipé
parce que tu aurais fait asie à la place
de chine je sais pas si un un joueur
asiatique autre que chinois auraient pu
rentrer dans cette équipe j'ai pas
l'impression le kong mais non ils
rentrent pas un nom du moment la russie
là réussissent toriques mans pour les
échecs ça semble logique qu'elle y
participe par elle même parce que c'est
un énorme pays des chèques bien
évidemment absolument
l'un d'eux lundi par l appareil
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de ce
défi c'est difficile de savoir comment
comment diviser l'europe est exactement
avec l'inde et en asie mais bon j'avais
pensé faire un genre de réveillon la
verte erin ans mais ça paraît logique
d'avoir fait un don je pense que je
pense que tout est logique mais bon
voilà le format peut être allé un peu
être élargies un plus grand nombre de
types pourquoi pas une équipe de france
bah oui les années à venir
on espère les fameux coq est de retour
pour reperdre encore une fois pour
reperdre encore aux éliminatoires contre
entre nakamura tout seul non mais s'agit
il devrait vous aurez juste nakamura
petit simultanées alors on reprend à
17h01 c'est sa cabine
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça fait que dès
qu'on commence à voir les compositions
on va pouvoir ainsi que ça va ça écoute
ça commence à tomber
je pensais que ça tombe à 45 c'est pour
ça que j'étais pas sur le coup mais on a
les compos alors
ben écoute kasparov qui qui a changé son
fusil d'épaulé et il a trouvé son équipe
type apparemment puisque cette fois ci
pas de remplacement d'accord donc moi je
moi je me serais je me serais bien
attendu à ce que parce qu'ils disent a
dude un coût de tels partis j'ai un peu
plus mais finalement finale finalement
je pense que peut-être que gary qui est
lui-même un grand joueur d'attaqué
préfère préfère voir d'où d'akita voire
de trois parties catastrophique de temps
en temps
plutôt que le style plus conservateur
d'aniche surtout avec les blancs
puisqu'il aura les blancs ou trois où il
à l oral et blanc du coup c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un choix logique mais les
deux les deux en fait duda et à duda
guérit les deux avec les blancs kantari
krishna c'est plutôt c'est plutôt un bon
apparemment parce que guy il peut
vraiment un
ils peuvent vraiment obtenir un bel
avantage d'un ouverture contrarie
krishna qui est beaucoup moins bien
préparés attention à au deuxième et chic
et c'est un match qui me fait un petit
peu peur entre visiter les bonnes j'ai
l'impression que dans le sport en
général le mec en grande forme contre
celui en très mauvaise forme ces apps
est porteur de surprise cette histoire
là moi je pense pas moi je ressens je
pense que je peux bien pour les vannes à
mon avis les indiens mais si j'étais
capitaine de l'équipe indienne je dirais
avidité coutelle et blanc tu essayes de
faire nul parce que parce qu'avec les
blancs c'est voilà avec les blancs c'est
plus facile de bétonner d'essayer de
tenir le match nul qu'avec les noirs et
là je pense pas que ça soit l'échiquier
sur laquelle sur lequel l'un d'eux doit
compter à mon avis l'un doit plutôt
essayer de gagner au quatrième avec koné
ou avec les blancs contre mu et chioukhs
et après les trois autres partis tout
est possible évidemment mais bon des
français à mon avis sauf les français je
me trompe pas encore les européens
cette équipe deraedt et est favorite sur
sur les 3 premiers échiquiers ne peut
évidemment de très peu mais voilà alors
allemande s'est pas forcément un joueur
qui réussit très bien maxime vachier
lagrave
donc ce sera un match
intéressant non mais les blancs les
blancs d'un porte souvent convaincant en
tout cas prennent souvent davantage dans
leur parti et maxime a gagné quelques
parties convaincante avec les blancs
contre un norn ça va dépendre de comment
il se sort de l'ouverture c'est toujours
pareil attendait tellement bien préparé
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a joué autant
de matches de championnat du monde je
l'expliquais l'autre jour alors
peut-être que c'était pendre quand on a
quand ont commenté les candidats que je
devais expliquer mais des joueurs qui
ont joué des matches de championnat du
monde c'est à dire des matches des
matches de finale de championnat du
monde où ils se préparent pendant des
mois
voilà où les secours où il ya tout il ya
plus à plusieurs sponsors où il ya plus
d'un million d'euros parfois 2 3
millions d'euros de prix pour deux
joueurs donc un budget énorme pour se
préparer
ces joueurs là qui ont de jouer ces
matches-là ont tellement de mal à son
thème ont bien préparé dans les débuts
de partie parce qu'ils ont pu avoir des
entraîneurs à plein temps pendant des
mois voire des années
même voilà donc même même aujourd'hui à
nantes qui n'est plus qu'il joue plus
vraiment pour le titre de champion du
monde va tout ça il a en stock et alors
pour arriver à prendre un avantage dans
début de partie alors que c'est un
joueur connaît tellement de choses c'est
pas facile même avec les plantes pour
pau maxime va chez des rates qui lui
aussi commence à être bien préparé mais
c'est vrai que c'est jamais facile de
mettre sous pression
un joueur de la qualité de de vichy mais
bon on peut on peut quand même espérer
que maxime prennent prennent davantage
avec les blancs dans cette partie pour
pour la team europe
absolument je vais tenter au trophée les
échecs sont voilà les échecs sont un jeu
très concret voilà dans un sport dans un
sport plus physique
voilà le joueur le joueur en pleine
bourre contre
voilà contre le joueur qui voilà qui
prend qui prend un petit peu d'âge qui
veut qui va entre guillemets vers la
retraite le jeune joueur va forcément va
forcément réussir à prendre le dessus au
moins physiquement alors que la aux
échecs qu'il est possible dans le début
de partie que même avec les blancs
maxime se fasse dominé par allende qui a
qui a accumulé les connaissances et des
connaissances et des connaissances
depuis des années parce que les échecs
c'est un jeu vraiment voilà très concret
très concret et voilà beaucoup qui
dépend beaucoup de la préparation des
ordi avec les ordinateurs etc
je suis sûr que même aujourd'hui
l'accord un an d'encore une équipe de
réparateurs derrière lui donc je te
laisse le blé un droit de réponse
j'étais en train de regarder quelle
quelle tentative tu nous faisais je suis
impatient de savoir donc alors les armes
tuent nous tu m'as dit qu'on avait les
appariements donc effectivement on a
parlé des appariements entre l'europe et
l'inde avec maxime vachier lagrave
contre vishy anand à rognan avec les
pièces noires contre-visite duda avec
les blancs contre harry krishna et use
it choc avec les noirs contre cuneo
il ya un gros match à côté russie chine
même si la russie maintenant plus ou
moins éliminé avec nepomniachi contre
digne rennes artemiev contrevent gao
car yakine contre wade et gorillaz
finale contre où il fane un match bas où
la chine est favorite un encore comme
d'habitude et le reste du monde contre
les états unis alors s'il reste du monde
pouvait nous faire une petite surprise
et battre les états unis ça nous
arrangerait bien nous la team europe
alors reste du monde qui a sorti
radjabov qui joue avec fear hunza au
premier avec thé blanc contre nakamura a
mine d'asse basséenne contre caruana
avec les noirs georges corrie avec le
péruvien avec thé blanc contre wesley so
et maria music show classeur de de la
soeur danna music shop maria qui jouent
contre irina croche avec les noirs
un match quand même où les états unis
sont favoris mais un match un match qui
reste ouvert quand même s'il reste du
monde arrive à être assez solide au
milieu de vos 2e et 3e échiquier ils
peuvent
voilà ils ont des possibilités ils sont
favoris sur l'échiquier féminin donc
voilà qui s'est hissé le reste du monde
malgré malgré leur dernière place au
classement ce n'est pas une équipe de
peintres un seul à tout et tout est
possible
n'hésite pas à prendre deux trois
questions du chat pendant que j'essaye
de récupérer la caméra j'ai une petite
appréhension du coup je les avais pas
sur le même écran que le chat alors tu
veux qu'à l'équipe pour les appariements
une autre tellement bien qui peut
racheter conforama
forcément j'ai donné les appariements on
a donc c'est mon petit peu cela je suis
comment se passe ta petite tentatives
d'exploits technique dans un temps à
écouter ça se passe plutôt bien
ça se passe plutôt bien d'accord alors
si vous aussi vous fait que dit romain
le blaze de qualité ou faire des blagues
sur conforama vous mais si rien sur quoi
rebondir alors posez moi quelques
questions pronostics romain alors
pronostics romain et regardez pas compte
pas exact je vois bien une victoire de
duda je vois bien une victoire d'are
oignons je vois bien je vois bien une
victoire au moins trois de la team
europe dans ce dans ce match le sens car
je sens qu à rognan et duda voilà je
semble que jude avec les blancs va
vouloir se refaire et à rené on a eu des
partis il va rien lâcher
écoute moi qui pensais qu'ils avaient
besoin d'une petite table basse devant
mon canapé je vais peut-être m'offrir
tes services parce que tu m'as l'air
d'être très très fonds pour pour bloquer
entre fable est alors née zapata grand
direct chasse illégale sont sympas et
compte
bonne question j'ai d'autres chats tu en
fais tu sur ton partage d'écran kevin ce
qui fait que je ne peux pas remonter
voir avec des questions que j'ai pu
rater selon un calendrier prévisionnel
ou là où devrais tu être en ce moment
alors en ce moment je devrais être en
angleterre je devrais en train de jouer
là la fina de la formation de chasse
league donc la finale de league anglaise
qui se joue et les 8 9 et 10 mai donc
vers vers birmingham
c'est là que je devrais être aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs j'aurais dû prendre j'aurais
dû prendre l'avion là il ya quelques
heures si si le monde était normale aux
jours de chaleur grandir au jour
d'aujourd'hui désolé pro tu peux le dire
t'inquiète pas pour le chat
en tout cas en tout cas du coup tu dois
bien être content de ce continent
puisque ça te permet de passer
l'après-midi avec nous absolument
absolument attend bien ceux d'ailleurs
j'en profitais ce que je peux déjà
attisé par écoute je tisse si je dis une
connerie c'est tant pis je genou mais
mal tout de suite mais est ce qu'on peut
déjà dire contre retrouvera bientôt sur
check point comme pour des vidéos de
type qualitative j'ai cru entendre
parler de ça j'ai cru voir des mails
passé alors oui effectivement on a
quelques on a quelques projets de vidéos
pédagogiques mais en a pas on sait pas
encore exactement sur quoi on a discuté
des formats soit sur des petites vidéos
de de 15 minutes
mais plusieurs vidéos de 15 minutes sur
un même sur un même sujet donc voilà
plusieurs chapitres on va dire et je les
ferai normalement en français et en
anglais ça c'est un peu la bonne
nouvelle qu'on
qu'on pouvait je voulais vous annoncer
du coup au passage ça que je suis assez
impatient de voir ta série de vidéos
arrivé à titre personnel romain et sache
que je les regarderai c'est vrai de pas
te décevoir
line renaud je ne m'inquiète pas du tout
pour ça mais je suis un petit peu
impatient de voir ça sortir parce que
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être quelque
chose qui manquait un peu enfin qu'il
manquait un peu les dents les choses à
mon avis qui manquait pour les
abonnements premium chaise comme on a
bossé sur les leçons je sais pas si tu
as eu l'occasion de voir on en a fait
une 125 125 leçon de quatre minutes cinq
minutes
donc c'est quelque chose que j'ai fait
en collaboration avec chaises comme pour
le français mais il nous manquait des
des séries vraiment par un joueur
français du top niveau et je suis je
suis assez assez curieux de voir ce que
tu va nous apporter écoute je vais
essayer de justice et bien j'ai essayé
de faire de mon mieux
donc je vais essayer de prendre un
maximum de choses en un minimum de temps
puisque aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on nous
demande en vidéo
donc voilà avec des vidéos de 15 minutes
s'il va falloir être concis et voilà
c'est de donner un maximum de conseils
de montrer voilà un maximum d'exemple
dans un lit trop vite non plus j'espère
que ça plaira et surtout que ça plaira à
nos à nos auditeurs
il n'y a pas de danger il n'y a pas de
danger
à mon avis elle rentre demande romain
travail tue encore beaucoup les échecs
ou je les travaille moins que quand
j'étais joueur à plein temps mais bon je
travaille encore un petit peu façon
quand je travaille comme je travaille
pour singer stoli shabby chic pour comme
je suis éditeur de livres d'échec
je reçois beaucoup de matériel des
chèques sur lequel je dois travailler
avant de le mettre en forme et de
transformer en bouquin parce que je ne
travaillais pas que sur mes bouquins
mois mais sur les bouquins aussi écrit
par nos autres auteurs est donc déjà
celle du travail d'échec parce que voilà
je vérifie tout s'il ya des je veux pas
laisser des rares passé dans nos
bouquins donc voilà un bouquin à
n'importe quel bouquin qui sort de ses
cages de bichiques gelé forcément scruté
et travailler donc bien que ça c'est
déjà beaucoup de travail
des chèques romain que penses tu du
retour de ou ifan
alors ouais wichman j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien qu'elle joue la voir
jouer un maximum parce que à l'heure
actuelle c'est la meilleure joueuse du
monde et c'est vraiment dommage de ne
pas l'avoir je ne veux pas la voir dans
le circuit des championnats du monde
voilà ça n'intéresse pas mais s'est
fortement s'est fortement dommage pour
pour les échecs
alors en ce moment a fait ses études à
oxford à moins qu'elles viennent de deux
thèmes de terminer mais en tout cas
l'année dernière et à oxford et donc
voila l adami un petit peu les échecs de
côté je trouve ça plutôt bien voilà
d'avoir envie de faire de plusieurs
choses dans la vie et et voilà d'avoir
les capacités surtout d'aller dans une
grande université mais évidemment tant
que joueur d'échecs jeu ça me ferait
plaisir de la voir jouer davantage
c'est une énorme joie elle a aussi été
au dessus de 2007 ou pas la tourne
autour de 2007 et les athètes dépassez
pas que je crois pas qu'elle ait eus
2007 mais elle était pas loin du tout
alors toi quel cursus tu as suivi tient
question est ce que tahri cursus
universitaire aussi ou pas du tout j'ai
le bac j'ai un bac scientifique
mais après non je me suis mis aux échecs
je me suis mis aux échecs après le bac
voilà je voulais quand même obtenir mon
bac je dois avouer que voilà j'ai choisi
les échecs
bien avant d'avoir mon bac 2 3 ans avant
d'avoir mon peu d'avoir mon bac je
savais que j'allais choisir les échecs
ce qui fait que mes résultats scolaires
après n'ont pas été voilà n'ont pas été
ce que qu'ils auraient été certainement
sans les échecs mais j'ai quand même
voilà fait l'effort d'aller jusqu'au bac
pour obtenir ce bagage et et de
l'obtenir et ensuite je me suis mis aux
échecs je me suis posée chaque à fond à
plein temps et tu regrettes tu ne
regrette pas non j'ai vraiment aucun
regret même si voilà au début j'étais
parti dans l'idée d'être strictement
joueurs et puis finalement un moment
donné voilà j'ai décidé de faire
d'autres choses
voilà des livres des vidéos d'être voilà
j'ai même été donc seconde ans j'ai des
élèves aussi je vois la jeune quelques
cours donc je suis décidé à un moment
donné après de me diversifier mais voilà
je regrette quand même pas du tout ma
décision d'avoir
les échecs comme plan de carrière voilà
j'aime j'aime ce que je fais et
finalement c'est pas quelque chose que
c'est pas une chance que tout le monde a
donc est-ce que tu laisse la porte
ouverte éventuellement à une
reconversion totale c'est-à-dire de lave
et de faire quelque chose qui n'aurait
plus du tout rapport avec les échecs que
ce soit de près ou de loin
écoute la question c'est la question
c'est quoi parce que ça m'intéresse de
faire quelque chose une chose dans
laquelle j'estime avoir quand même
certaines certaines compétences donc je
me vois pas faire un boulot holanda
après un projet à projet intéressant à
ou au monde
voilà un projet intéressant où je
pourrai apporter certaines voilà
certaines certaines compétences utiles
qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont rien à voir
avec les échecs voilà si une opportunité
se présente et vous écoute on va se
retrouver dans le bâtiment on va te
retrouves énorme et je me vois pas
quitter le monde des échecs comme
l'avait fait joël lautier par exemple
mais dray qui a complètement quitté le
monde des échecs mais je les ai vus il
ya quelques jours d'ailleurs joël g
j'ai déjeuné avec lui et je vais
demander si prévoyez un jour quand même
de retoucher un échiquier médiane quand
on prend cette décision
j'ai pris cette décision de me
reconvertir de laisser les échecs et une
décision à vie voilà moi je pense pas
que ça m'arrivera je pense que je pense
pas que j'arriverais à lâcher même si
j'avais une opportunité comme joël de la
dette allait faire quelque chose de
faire quelque chose d'autre même un gros
boulot je pense pas que j'arriverais à
tirer un trait sur les échecs c'est
voilà c'est un trimé toute ma vie les
échecs donc alors où est ce que joël est
toujours en russie je crois je suis
battu à nous confirmer sa joie elle est
revenue en europe
un jeune est revenu en europe tu vois je
savais pas alors regarde la surprise du
chef
regard des caméras
atao chez nous m 2 caméras à saissac
heat a pris 1 ça on a eu quelques
problèmes techniques les premiers jours
c'est en fait tout était à kate est en
stress quatre jours pour mettre ses deux
caméras kevin comment tu expliques que
je peux expliquer ça peut intéresser à
des personnes en réalité c'est
d'habitude quand on fait des
compétitions avec deux trois quatre
joueurs ont réussi facilement à le
fermer
mais on est un petit problème technique
vu le nombre de joueurs qu'on a pour les
réunir sur la même réunion et donc il a
fallu que j'ai l'aide d'un collègue
on a trouvé ce matin une solution
alternative pour réussir à faire cette
promesse n'est pas une prouesse
technique mais pour réussir à avoir les
deux caméras c'est la première fois
qu'on fait un événement avec avec autant
de devoirs en même temps doux ceci
explique cela
d'accord d'accord un an à nantes qui est
une posture amusante sur la vidéo maxime
très concentré un an de nature de bonne
humeur ah non tu sais pas j'arrive pas à
expliquer puis la donne et leïla il un
regard un peu préoccupé
ouais mais je paye ce que des petites
têtes il est marrant j'aime bien je sais
pas est ce que les joueurs se voient
entre non il se fera pas entre eux en
fait peut-être que vous êtes aussi
non non ils sont sûrs comme ya beaucoup
de joueurs ils sont sur des conférences
avec des passes qui avait beaucoup
d'arbitrés aussi mais un accord donc il
ya deux arbitres par équipe ou trois
arbitres je sais plus exactement mais à
mais du coup ça ça pose des petites des
petites complications et d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que normalement après
après les matches on se quittera avec
romain mais je récupère et peut-être
maxime pour un petit moore à la fin pour
un petit mot le dernier mot de la fin
reviendra peut-être à maxime aujourd'hui
à vérifier peut-être le cyber il ne
voudra pas dire quoi que maxime toujours
de bonne humeur mais en plus il va pas
perdre
du coup le problème est résolu d'anglais
exactement à non-dits fume plus monde
avec son vieil ans de kad merad dit tout
il fume tout le monde avec avec son
angle de caméra
oui c'est son angle de caméra ouais
c'est ça en fait
scor est elle bien par deux sous la
caméra de vie chère a tancé en train de
partir dont je vois les joueurs qui y
voilà alors the lion's best seller
pseudo the light list contre eux et 4 de
maxime donc donc maxime qui est en train
de changer complètement son répertoire
des saints qui peut prendre il va jouer
cinq petites structures karzaï une
nouvelle fois nouvelle fois on va voir
si un an de la maîtrise un tout petit
peu mieux que apoel fsa de détroit là
ils ont largué alors quitte à largs it a
largué à la théorie alors en fait flouer
f5 c'est la variante 2
car jouer chronique plusieurs fois
normalement le coût principal ces dames
f3 sur f5 parce que fo ap cinq c'est un
coup intéressant pour éviter food et 3
enfin pour éviter s'empêche pas fou
detroit mais qu'on pourrait échanger des
fous le problème c'est l'essentiel d'un
f3 qui force se fout g6 et cette finale
avec fu principe six daims prend et
cette structure affaibli pour les blancs
pour les noirs et voilà cette finale qui
est censé être mieux pour les blancs
mais très difficile à très difficile à
gagner
une maxime à innover un petit peu avec
dame b3 et les coûts après d'un v6 foot
- m6 on peut après on croit des deux
d'accord qui prévoit royal de dire qu'il
prévoit la finale où le roi sera bien
placé au centre ils essayent d'avoir une
finale avec la colonne à qui souffre
d'un grand baie 3 à tomber trois
estiment que c'est une meilleures
finales que il veut faire fou détroit
j'imagine alors je sais pas trop oui
apparemment oui il a fait tous des toits
c'est extraordinaire vous prendrez 3 il
pourra le roi en d3 en milieu de jeu
c'est rarissime c'est rarissime
on vous prend des trois il ya encore
tant de sueurs dame prend des six mâts
mon avis il veut pas prendre cette dame
investissement non je crois tu vraiment
monter et sur un échec tant pis il
reparle
ouais mais cavaliers b6 grox un peu
bizarre là quand même autour d un cri
ck3 c1
ouais il jouer une finale j'ai une
position avec où il a fait fi des
structures de pions adverse tout
simplement pas idiot du tout comme bien
et mathieu cornette ses space mountain
on nous dit jouan king of the hill
maxime si c'est une variante des échecs
ou le but est de ramener le roi sur
l'une de ces quatre cases ce qui rend
ici parce que tu penses que c'est
théorique pour pour les blancs je ne
sais pas bien c'est possible que ce soit
c'est possible que ce soit déjà nouveau
là la position marrante caste idée
s'avère très intéressant tout cas canon
qui va pouvoir garder les dames mais
voilà le roi en d2 qui est quand même
solide
ici on peut essayer de ramener un
cavalier un f4 par exemple annoncer fin
bingguo sont partis ouais challenge qui
se touchent les cheveux du coup alors
les autres ça va être alors de nouveau
qu'on trouve duda et j'ai envie de te
dire eux police fighter c'est la même
structure d'options mais pas la même
position c'est un peu inquiétant vu
comment montana traité dans la partie
précédente c'est lui qui furent alors là
il vient de se prendre une leçon avec
les noms alors s'ils arrivent à
appliquer la même chose côté blanc sera
parfait ouais c'est vrai aussi
il sort d'une dix ans d'un cours il sort
il sort d'un concours long pénible mais
fortement instructif alors voyons s'il
arrive quelque chose
visite donc l'homme en méforme avec les
blancs face à l'homme en forme justement
les bonnes avec un renoir reprend cette
variante qui avait été joué au tournoi
des candidats par alex cenco contre
caruana une position ici très très
complexe mais je crois qu'alex ngom et
une position complètement corrects un
email innocent ou alors ici il avait
perdu la partie de façon assez limpide
mais d'après voilà d'après les modules
d' analyse il était possible d'améliorer
effectivement le jeu des noirs combat en
qui j'ai une variante risque est ici un
vraiment une proposition à double
tranchant avec déjà un pion passé pour
les blancs en d6 une menace de
fourchette avec ssl donc un an donc là
donc ce pion dassier ce qui peut devenir
une faiblesse un jour un message à une
position à double tranchant donc à royan
qui veut à mon avis qu'ils vont enfoncer
un peu plus l'homme l'homme en méforme
tourbe et 8 c le talk ou sa lettre au
coût de l'ordinateur
certainement et on jette un oeil vers
les dernières ific est pour se faire un
petit tour des stades
avec une défense slave et s'éprend des
cinq essais 3 donc on a une espèce de
slaves des changes bizarre où le fou
noir est arrivé à angers 4 et le
football on est enfermé en c1 d'habitude
dans la fosse table des changes il va
plutôt avec 4 se fout donc oui c'est un
peu bizarre mais bon ajout très vite
donc ça va être une préparation
il me semble que quand on joue et
s'éprend des 5 c'était pour jouer au 6e
coup n'ont pas calé ses trois médailles
b3 pour attaquer bessette et essayer de
faire cavalier de 5 alors je ne dis pas
que c'est une variante qui était censé
donner quelque chose selon note la
théorie un mur en tout cas il temps de
ça avec avec les noirs se propose qu'on
retourne du côté de maxime pour voir un
peu comment ce roi s'en sort et
finalement et finalement vichy qui a qui
a craqué le premier sur le conflit des
dames et qui a décidé d'échanger et qui
a mis son cavalier investissent une
casque je trouve un petit peu étrange
romain pour un cavalier puisqu'il vient
directement se lancent tout je deviens
un secret à mon avis ce cahier il finira
en d6 l'affairé skah se décide dans la
carlsbad
voilà et le voici les noix arriver à
mettre le fond b4 il peut être bien
protégé par un pion à 5
quelques cavaliers en d6 la position
nord serait à mon avis correct c'est
comme ça que à mon avis c'est comme ça
que les noirs doivent essayer de jouer
mais voilà faut b4 on va chasser par
cavalier ou un cavalier avril à jockey
h4 de mer paris vise la kdf 5 aussi pour
un leroy ben 17 un cavalier f5 et puis
puis j'ai essayé de faire h4
maine-et-loire vont faire h5 peut-être
l'autre cavaliers du coup qui pourrait
venir par là peut-être effectivement
l'autre cavalli qui peut incarner un f5
kyi qui défend bien qui défend bien qui
empêche un qui restera un petit peu le
foot cases noires le faut et fuite n'a
plus trop de cadres et car il arrive
cinq qui peut qui peut de capturer un
remarques mais bon les blancs
reprendront avec échec ça devrait plutôt
être une bonne chose pour
pour les blancs donc ici peut-être
peut-être 4,5 et purge en tête un coup
de g4 pour paralyser les noirs qui ne
peuvent pas vraiment joué h5 à cause du
fou g6 et peut-être f4 au prochain coup
évidemment un ton plus puisque lé nord
veulent pas échangé en d3 parce qu'après
trois pans des trolls le canadien m5
sera vraiment trop bien passé et où ça
pose une question ça pose une question
sérieuse et le prochain coup ça pourrait
être f4 f5
or ces échanges des changes en d3
éventuellement intéressant romain ce
début de partie quand même pour maxime
ex ce roi plutôt plutôt bien placés en
finalement seront en d2 qui fait le
boulot en ces pièces active il protège
le foot est roi
finalement et il peut pas vraiment être
attaqué un difficile à mettre en échec
le cavalier qui peut pas venir l'attaqué
et le roi qui en sécurité dans cette
finale c'est ça mon avis tout l'idée de
maxime de jouer cette finale est de se
faire échanger les dames en b3 et
d'avoir ce pion en b3 plutôt qu'en à
deux donc complètement à l'opposé de
nous apprendre aux échecs mais c'est à
dire qu'il préfère voir des pions doublé
que des pions st mais en fait voilà ses
pions des mythes beaucoup de contres jeu
des noirs et les blancs ou maintenant
pouvoir s'emparer de la loi et ici je
prends là j'aime vraiment bien les
blancs après g4 je pense que c'est le
coût qui va jouer à maxime se g4 et
maxime maxime qui va j'espère nous
sortir une grosse partie parce qu'on va
on va en avoir besoin dans ce match on
l'a dit notre petit point faible peut
être au quatrième et chic y est et ff iv
4 d'accord alors ils provoqueront avec
la même idée en fait il va provoquer des
changes
parce que là la menace est quand même
être cinq le fou sera obligé d'aller en
h5
attention je parle encaissé 8 f 5 x 5 et
peut-être h34 imparable et noir vont
perdre une pièce ça c'est pas possible
côté noir la provoquer l'échangé le fou
qui vient en d4
l'autre point positif de ces pions
doublet c'est que sur france et rend
pourrait reprendre de b alors là on
ramènerait avait grandement d'options
vers le centre tout le monde au centre
je trouve quand même kiev 4 c'était
c'est un peu tôt j'aurais plutôt préparé
avec les blancs j'aurais pu j'aurais
plutôt préparé jamais vraiment bien j'ai
4 avant de jouer f4 peut-être voilà
prendre un tour qu'est-ce qui veut rien
dire je sais pas trop ce que maxime huot
faire et ce qu'il veut faire
4 je le voyais plutôt faire tour est
fait un tour f 3 tours h36 voulais faire
quelque chose avec cette tour ouais même
si ça me paraissait aventureux mais toi
donc toi ce crédit qui revient vers des
six mois il va mettre le serveur f5
j'imagine ou quatre et ils jouent à
toute blinde histoire de bien énervé
notre ami gary alors le cas ça me paraît
vraiment étonnant comme courant ouais
surtout qu'après puis on prend 1 4 des 6
les n'organise attention cavaliers sur
la tour pardon je leur on peut repartir
et ce qu'il ya du ksk du tour à 4 puis
cavalia 2 mais bon j'ai l'impression que
les noirs ont résolu plus ou moins leurs
problèmes quand même je mange je suis un
peu surpris là par la crosse de maxime
oui c'est un peu surprenant et alors
peut-être côte est qui est en nous
disant de châtel ce que maxime prendre
du roi ce que c'est pas ça t'a variante
du nil humains oui c'est le king of the
hill oui la saga n'y arriverai google
faisait il à gagner gagner tout de suite
ça ouais ça se gagne futur arrive sur
une des quatre cas c'est fini
t'as jamais joué à ce jeu marcoing
talent et compliquées a en tout cas la
partie elle suit ce dont parlait quatre
prises de 4.4 il a remis la tour en e2
mais je vois pas pourquoi on devrait
avoir des problèmes ici parce qu'il ya
j'aime pas eu tout ce qu'avait j'aime
pas du tout ce qu'a fait maxime alors
maxime n'est pas moins bien non plus un
attention si il veux faire ma vie
cavaliers ou 4 échangé ce cavalier c'est
pour ça qu'il n'a pas fait cavalière 5e
il veut faire cavalier ou quatre pour
échanger plus tôt le cas et c'est 3 et
ensuite remettre l'ordre cavalia f5 et
le fonds des quatre est tellement fort
et tient la case hausse est il tient
tout je vois pas du tout je pense pas
qu'ils aient le moindre avantage ici
pour pour les blancs il prend la case un
petit tour de stade
allez c'est une bonne idée alors on va
les faire on va le faire dans l'ordre
cette fois ci et on va aller voir notre
buteur notre buteur écoute qui un masque
et ramasser un pion
d'après ce que je vois mais qui est mal
autant ça c'est un peu inquiétant parce
que ça a l'air d'être un truc assez
théorique schéma l'otan afrique 19
minutes
ouais envie dit qu'ils jouent tempo qui
a 26 minutes 14 donc une préparation de
visite avec moins l'ordinateur qui
al'air d'estimer qu' à des compensations
à peu près pour le pion mais sapin pas
non plus se parait pas catastrophique
pour les noirs les blancs sont très
actifs et effectivement ils vont mettre
une tour par exemple tours 1
ça me paraît pas plus dangereux que ça
pour pour les noirs mais bon ça a l'air
d'aller
ensuite on a ou la la ça s'anime
on peut peut-être soir passé c'est
rapide et bien on l'avait dit que doudou
wade allait vouloir se refaire
ouais il faut se refaire la cerise sur
bentalha donc c'était cette seconde vie
dame romain ouais donc tout ça on avait
vu il a fait h4 à larache 4 qui invitait
fou prend h4 mais les noms n'ont pas
pris a pris le pion les sicile et s'il
devait celui des blancs essaient de
profiter d'une avance de développement
etc ou des noirs sont vraiment bizarre
cavalli a juste cavale et achète que les
fuites
désolé on passe en accéléré pour avoir
le temps de voir un peu tout le reste et
le placent en pièces noires romain est
vraiment comment il a joué des coups
quatre décès faire au 5e jeu pouvait
qu'aller à chaussettes comme la fuite m
laurent arrive 7
ça a l'air d'être bon salaire de
n'importe quoi avec f4 f5 qui va arriver
ouais ça pourrait être la bonne nouvelle
côté européen c'est vrai que c'est
spécial c'est spécial mais f4 f5 et qui
va arriver c'est les deux prochains de
coup j'ai l'impression à l'écran roch
ancien champion h4 quand même oui peu
comment on peut commencer par grand rush
tranquillement ouais ça paraisse
apparaître une construction un petit peu
douteuse duda c'est tour est un symbole
en fait on voit la même position à
chaque fois sauf que des fois il est du
bon côté des fois du mauvais coup ouais
c'est ça ouais c'est soit ils massacrent
soleil se fait massacrer alors et la
partie entre nos 2 sous b 4 échecs blanc
qui peuvent tout est changé ici d'un me
prends des quatre caves et prend des
quatre fous prendre soin d'eux se serait
pas spécialement dangereux non mais
voilà position à peu près égale
certainement on retourne chez maxim ton
de chez maxim donc maxime qu'a obtenu
son jolie cavalière f5 mais bon avec le
fonds des quatre comme ça
6 3 pour aller en f3 la tournée on va
s'activer en e1
alors quand même un atout reste trois
tours à choix quand même mais surtour la
la tourache trois tours b un temps
celles jouées chaque d'abord peut-être
abc c'est ce qui peut pas remettre le
cavalier en deux trois et ensuite faire
tour f3 là je commence à beaucoup aimé
la position de maxime tout à coup
l'occasion le 3 qui tient tout et puis
faire tour f3 tourage 3 et ensuite si la
tour noire est réduite à la passivité
revenir à f/5 du cavaly éventuellement
des frais à quai le trou avec l'idée de
fermer la porte de la tour wpt est
ensuite de faire tous rêvent 3 pourtour
h3 et l'euro en baisse ce qui justifie
complètement cavaliers 3 puisque bon
alors c'est pas une menace cavalli échec
mais c'est toujours bien d'avoir un
échec
ça peut toujours être pratique de
pratique d'avoir un échec effectivement
il a fait cavalier à troyes et tours des
huit d'accord qu'il ya des problèmes
peut-être x avec ces simples mais si ça
fout c'est ça qui a menacé ça arrive ça
arrive je vais montrer ses seins
caresser 2 comprend des cafés et prend
des quatre et c5 manoir et récupère la
tourne à quang phu c5 une menace donc la
maxime doit probablement écrit cavaliers
ces deux émanant surtout c'est ça qui va
bouger droit par exemple on sait qu'à 3
c3 et ensuite faire tour f3 certainement
way et ils couvrent toutes les cases
d'entrée de la tour 1 / noir c'est pas
mal et il peut se permettre de faire tes
preuves et 4 à tout moment ça peut ça
sera ça donnerait probablement pas grand
chose or là sur ces 5 qu'est ce qui se
passe par contre ce qui me ferait jeu
presque réception des scorpions
entourage 3 effectivement et à un
superbe le blocus la surface blanche
contrôler toutes les cases
effectivement ce très joli ouais donc
une pole position il peut très vite mal
tourner pour 1
pour vichy il joue bien un maxime il
joue très bien on voit la caméra les
deux joueurs belges comptant les ordres
sur la caméra
j'en profite j'en profite 3-1 tant
d'efforts pour les avoir un homme il
nous fait le show là sur le canal web
après y'a pas énormément d'émotion à sur
le visage des joueurs non ils sont prêts
concentré effectivement 11e bellamy à la
nand l'humour c'est ça un problème dont
elles ont besoin d'expliquer ces 5 to
h3c prend des quatre tours h 3 1
domination complète sur cases blanches
apparaissent options de des cats on
finira par le récupérer mais on n'est
pas pressé en fait les noirs aimerait
bien l'enlever ce pion des quatre pour
faire échec et faire rentrer la tour
mais à cause du puy en d4
les noirs n'ont aucun point d'entrer ici
ni sur la colonne des nids sur la
colonne eu ni sur la colonne c'est tout
est contrôlé ses jolies est vraiment
très jolie a un très joli blocus ça
rappelle un petit peu la partie
la partie a remis à rené envies
d'ailleurs alors il fait quelque chose
de très malin vichy veut provoquer j'ai
trois en cinquante pions pour enlever la
manoeuvre torreilles froid courage 3 un
truc tu es un truc que tu es un truc
typîque dans ce genre de structure très
bien vrai
ce que le us europe a déjà eu lieu on
nous demande alors le match aller oui
mais pas le match retour le match retour
c'est pour demain tu le suivre en direct
d'ailleurs à je pense oui ça va être je
vois ce que je vois mon emploi du temps
de demain mais je vais essayer de poire
de pouvoir le suivre en direct et jeter
coûterait moins cher que tu seras d'une
femme hier demain ça a donné avec
mathieu cornette tu peux en est d'accord
moi je vous où il va y avoir beaucoup
d'infos théorique beaucoup de
révélations truc effectivement mathieu
un grand théoricien c'est une machine un
de ses origines de travail
impressionnant il connaît toujours tout
quand il connaît pas ça m'inquiète c'est
rare qu'ils connaissent pas quelque
chose en fait c'est dit qu'il connaît
pas de tête c'est qu'ils se rappellent
pas frais dans ses rares séries là il a
tout analysé via toutes analysées alors
on refait un petit tour ouais j'suis
d'accord alors notre joueuse
bon alors je suis toujours pas convaincu
par l'ouverture de koné au j'aime bien
la façon dont cette partie se passe pour
nous les bonnes la partie peut-être un
petit peu sensible moi mais ça a plus en
plus pour nous mais à une position
difficile à jouer et la dnef 8 il fait
une sacrée concession en laissant faire
tout reprend des quatre donc la vie dit
qu'un train de nous sortir une grosse
préparation au moment où hautmont
fallait pas le faire on lui demandait
pas ça du tout en fait on lui demandé
par m
on lui demandait juste de continuer et
on lui souhaite pas tout le malheur du
monde dans l'ue souhaitait quand même de
continuer sa série une petite une petite
route de plus quoi ouais voilà c'est ça
je me dis que ça un jour même s'il faut
atterrir ici fou prend f7 il peut enfin
devant la tour pour le vent les protéger
deux fois mais un jour tu vois il ya
même ça dans le viseur en plus j'ai pris
la dame rouge et 3 et est très bien
placé ça ça fait aucun doute
tout faux est le fief 3 est très fort 1
en finale ça peut être une très bonne
pièce mais là on va devoir on va voir un
peu comment ce liquide que mons l'équipe
dale position un moment donné les blancs
peuvent aussi prendre et si c'est rentré
avec la dame en ces 7 par exemple c'est
de prendre de plomber 7 ce genre de
choses ça semble d'orge notre note en
crise bon c'est notre buteur qui va
devoir jouer en défense 1 probablement
dit probablement mais bon la france est
déjà là
plusieurs parties qui a plusieurs partis
qui sont qui ont bien tourné pour lui
ont pensé qu'ils étaient en défense en
fait hélas que je vois chez tout à ça ne
l'est pas non plus
romain parce que je vois la jauge à
gauche où là alors il a perdu un avion
non mais je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec avec la jauge qu'est ce qui se
passe où pranger trois ordinateurs dit
d'alger 5 avantages noir mais après
petit rock sa valeur ça a l'air
complètement alors qu'havas diop 600 kg
est d'accord ça a l'air il veut contre
attaquer sur g2 je suis à peu près sûr
que les noirs sont pas mieux dans cette
position contrairement à ce que veut
dire la jauge ensemble contrairement à
ce que dit la jauge
mais effectivement beaucoup de caps a
peut-être qu'à pas mates
peut-être qu'il a fait avec quatre
absents trop tôt il ya lille nous a trop
écouté on voulait quand même peut-être
faire grand roque 1er
on était peut-être partie sur grand
roque en premier nom romain allemant
serait une bonne idée parce que là
pourquoi il veut faire dan v5
l'ordinateur parce que ça évite de rock
bon 5 aux actifs aussi c'est vrai et
puis là cavalier qui vient est sis
derrière fait d'abord passer la dame
il veut faire passer la tour ça ne
paraît pas être un coup facile à jouer
un poste petit rock c'est assez
terrifiant quand même mais après tu peux
le trouver car par obligation quoi
peut-être ouais je sais pas j'ai pas
quelle est la solution humaine ici les
mails à jouer je trouvais dame g51
d'accord ouais mais tu le trouves tu le
trouves par élimination peut-être avec
peut-être pas de façon il veut tellement
avoir envie d'éviter grand roque que du
ku'damm g5 devient une obligation
ouais c'est vrai quand tu fais petit
rock le jour où plonger disparaît il y
aura une pression ici effectivement
alors que 6 2 avait simplement mis son
roi de l'autre côté un crd 1 après il
pouvait faire tout ce qu'ils voulaient
de l'autre côté pourrait sacrifier vous
pouvez jamais rien se passer sur son roi
donc là il a fait oui la fine seul il a
eu il a fait une sévère faute comme une
sévère fautes de jugement en jouant f4
f5 trop vite et en permettant ce coup
dame g5 qui évite camp rock mais c'était
pas face c'était pas évident il faut il
faut avouer de faire de faire la
différence il fallait voir dame g5 déjà
comme mon avis en dames g5 y avait
aucune audience problème et blanc
allaient faire gros quand même s'il
voulait donc un match qui est loin
d'être simple on peut retourner chez à
chez maxim du coup qui va être
prépondérant dans ce match on a
peut-être besoin de sa victoire ici
alors là à nantes qui est en train de se
demander s'il doit faire [ __ ] en d4 ou
pas mais fou prend des cas qui à tour
ses sept tours sète pardon la tour ne
peut pas s'interposer parce que sinon on
échangerait et cavaillé seraient des
clous et voir partir donc tour cet échec
et noir de votre parti avec le roi et la
tour-blanche commencerait ramasser tous
les pions fab le mans par exemple et f6
achète tout en l'air et les leroy qui
protège bien les pions blancs
ouais donc vous prendrez 4 pas possible
du coup qu'est ce que doit faire un
monde
il a fait tour des 5
d'accord donc sur g4 non il veut faire
fou prend des cats et je la mets au
final à part que le camp est 400 prises
à la fin probablement échec
ouais quelque chose comme ça maintenant
ouais mais là où aller en b 4 et blanc
vont être obligés de lâcher des plans
soit d'un côté soit de l'autre il va
réussir à prendre les deux pions il aura
trois pions passé lié ça va être
compliqué ouais donc tour des 5 maxime
peu style va éviter ça fait trois ou
quatre tout simplement attaquant le fou
au passage un attaquant le fou au
passage le fou à part avec lui tout en
baies 4 je sais toi fais tarifs pour
laisser tomber 5 éventuellement coincés
tour b5 et pour qu'on ait ans et pour
éviter cavaliers h ce qui pourra
éventuellement ram assure un pion nous
sommes parfois position qui reste
compliqué puissions compliqué maxime qui
va avoir du mal à gagner ça la can face
un ex-champion du monde ça va compter
bisous serait pas été évident
effectivement alors voyons voir les
vannes peut-être je vois qu'il est en
train de rattraper son retard à la
pendule donc toujours appuyé en avance
mais ce pion des quatre une grosse
faiblesse et la russie des noirs garde
le fouet avec kiev 3 mais c'est pas un
coup facile à jouer fouet f3 ferme la
socam la colonne de la tour ça rouvre la
colonne des qui peut permettre la
défense du pion plan décote wave 3 c'est
pas une décision facile n'y a pas ce que
tu as envie de jouer ça ouais mais
qu'elle prend des cinq maintenant dont
les blanches un peut-être un tout petit
peu mieux les contours des huit dames
des six quelque chose comme ça je pense
que ces scénarios logix un sas à
l'avenir est pas davantage
pour les blancs ou vraiment un avantage
très très symbolique donc effectivement
ci lui dit tu veux jouer pour le gain il
faut qu'ils gardent le fou mais bon faut
f3 tu peux aussi jouer pour la perte
tu peux aussi jouer pour la perte mais
finalement fait froid c'est quand même
embêtant parce que c'est vrai qu'elle va
cette dame g3 qui contrôlent beaucoup de
cases la tourbe et 8,6 obligé de rester
des chantres de plomber le pion le pion
gbessi bessette et en k2 en cas de b6
par exemple manettes donc maintenant
tour d un tour des 8es dams et c'est
quelque chose comme ça a aidé anne decis
par exemple pour échanger les dames on
va échanger on va commencer à pousser
on peut prendre la tête mais je comptais
plus tôt échanger et poussé le penser et
puis on sait qui est assez monstrueux et
puis sans exception d une façon qui peut
se faire et qui voilà qui est la
majorité trois contre deux de l'autre
côté qui comptent pas trop le roi qui
s'éloigne en h suite alors qu'en finale
il faut ramener le roi le plus vite
possible au centre donc et noir ont un
peu de retard et j'ai l'impression
qu'après faux f3 les blanc et noirs une
position délicate
on va voir si le trouve un c'est pas
facile du tout hein nous on ne trouve
pas ce qu'on à l'aide de l'ordinateur
mais à mais c'est compliqué alors ça ça
dépend de son aide ça dépend de son état
d'esprit c'est compliqué avec zéro avec
un 10 points sur 5 prendre cette
décision de jouer faux est roi c'est
effectivement pas simple après par
élimination vu que cavaler prend des
cinq résoudre plus ou moins tous les
problèmes des noirs c'était le coup il a
joué dame e5 heureusement pour nous et
maintenant on peut prendre maintenant je
pense qu'on peut prendre autour des 8
des 3d 2d ce qu'il veut faire ça parce
que tu reprends amat effectivement cette
on sera obligé de faire un truc genre
d'analysé 8 mesdames et 8 qui protège
bien c'est un truc bizarre qu'ils ont
derrière peut-être est-ce qu'on peut
faire tour 17 ici avec est ce qu'on a le
temps de faire tour 17 avec les blancs
alors on fait tout reprendre
cinq dates waldam prend des cinq tours
prenait 5 tu perds le jeu pensant
cardinal parce que je vais 3h vite et
trop loin en fait maintenant près autant
que moi je tu as le temps d'avant ce du
début qui reste à la fin ouais mais il
fallait le montrer mes tours 17
peut-être plus tour point de cette dame
qu'on sait qu'à tu es bon peuvent le
récupérer leurs jambes et cette joie
josem des huit dames g8 dame prend des 4
mais là on a une égalité matérielle
parfaite et à ses yeux tout de suite
annuler il a pris en dessin car yvonne
ils appréhendent et 5 et sur dame prend
dessins qu'il est pas obligé de faire un
tour des multiples aussi faire et 6 très
tranquillement et sur dame prend des
quatre maintenant faire tourner vite ça
doit aller ça réussit un terminal
symboliquement moins bien mais mais bon
le banat dévoile en grande forme
peut-être tu vas trouver tour des huit
mais c'est pas évident après tourcoing
et sète de faire d'alger huit ans il
peut le trouver 1 et lyon il est
tellement grosse forme les bonnes donc
bon les bonnes ça va
ce qui est inquiétant ce qui peut être
décisive c'est finalement la partie de
duda où il est peut-être même plus mieux
moins bien je n'avais pas jusque là je
préférerais la joue peu avec thé blanc
quand même l'ordinateur a beau donner
une sorte d'égalité ça peut se passer
vite tourner au cauchemar mais c'est
vrai que les coûts noirs ici car il ya
trop une grosse menace et si
l'ordinateur dit vrai qu'on est noirs
peuvent simplement fait retours évitez
sacrifier la qualité
3 alors les coûts noirs sont assez
facile finalement et ensuite j'ai pris
un f5 menace maths et tout à coup c'est
vrai cavalier ou quatre cavaliers
insiste tout et kas noirs deviennent
deviennent parfaite montre un scénario
qui pourrait mal tourner c'est un
scénario catastrophique avec f4 f5 4 3
qui arrive ou h4h 3way ce serait qatar
ouais il a fait tout réussit
ouais enfin on est en train de passer
proche de la correctionnelle dans ce
match voilà ce qui peut faire flouer
cinq ici avant de faire cavalier 3
pourquoi c'est si mauvais que ça d'après
l'ordinateur que va dire 3 a abandonné
la case aux quatre pour la dame
la c4 a aussi un ouais mais j'éprouve 5
sans doute à suivre m et à la tour
kitsch et de pourquoi pas tout reprend
pas à cause du cloud âge mais même un
way en tout cas est tout à l'appui c est
jack ok pas en grande forme
on a un problème le troisième parce que
guiry c'était pas terrible et duda c'est
pas terrible non plus ouais on a quoi il
ferait pas de perdre ce match ça serait
embêtant ce sera embêtant parce qu'après
il non seulement il faudrait battre les
états unis mais c'est vrai aussi avoir
un meilleur goal avérage
mais il ya maxime vachier lagrave au
premier si à chaque fois qu'on vient un
petit peu progressé il ya des deux
comptant sur la caméra on le sent qu'il
est en switch ce que fait un angle parce
qu'il y avait maintenant cette idée de
remettre une tournage croire revenait
après g4 alors allende attaque le pion
pourquoi pour provoquer h3 et
complètement et limiter les idées de
mais maintenant le plan des blancs va se
situer ailleurs probablement
probablement essayer un moment donné par
exemple d'aller attaquer depuis henri
vii avec cavalli h schiste de forcer la
de paralyser la tour noire quelque part
peut-être rhin essayer de ramener le roi
way à l'ordinateur propose un très joli
coup cavaliers g7
tous et toutes nous est tout à fait
logique menace cavale de huit sa garde
de contrôler suroît 17
j'ai pas très envie de ce pourquoi est
une idée un tueur fou aux 7
on va bien il a reculé et jouaient ce
truc là voix
ouais mais aussi un moment on arrivait à
jouer des cinq aussi ouvrir la position
ça pourrait cependant maxime qui a joué
h 4 il n'a pas joué avec cavalli h6
unique a déjà sept niveaux logique aussi
j'ai peut-être réagissez g5 même ouais
il veut ça va des doubles et les pions
des noirs c'est vrai mais si ça peut te
fasse on avait la pression sur quatre
est un petit peu embêtante pour les
blancs ça paralyse un petit peu la tour
en le cas donc s'ils peuvent purger cinq
rangées 5 maxime a quand même un bel
avantage des espaces sa position était
désagréable à jouer côté noir non maxime
qui est en train de faire une grosse
finale 1 il est en train de l'adm a
raillé un romain min ou son truc avec
avec 4.4 mais finalement non c'est bien
vu de la part de maxime qui fait un
boulot extraordinaire dans cette partie
on va en avoir besoin puisque duda duda
nous déçoit doute à nous déçoit à on
peut juste faire on n'avait pas regardé
notre joueuse anna voulzy tchouk qui a
ma foi une excellente position avec les
noirs pas forcément gagnante mais on est
quand même content le roi blanc est un
peu plus faible et je regarde juste côté
les bons il a joué le f 6 et il reste un
petit peu sous pression là on voit là la
jauge là qui s'emballe un peu mais elle
est pas bien maintenant parce que les
blancs vont pousser leurs pions 2 ouais
il ya des problèmes d'ordre d'ordre
tactique
imaginons ici que les noirs jouent d'amd
cette voie il attaquerait même pas le
pion dessein car déjà il y aurait des
six mines attaquerait même pas le pion
des cinq parce qu'il y aurait toujours
et 8 échecs il dévie la tour la dame h
salle adam contrôler la case du roi donc
tout reprend et dame prend dame dont 14
très dur à trouver ce ceux d'alger 8 et
c'est assez c'est assez inhumain quand
même en tout cas on va vraiment avoir
besoin de 2 maximum dans ce match
absolument donc la maxime va jouer les
cinq à peu près sûr à moins qu'ils
commencent par cavani h6 et sur fg il va
reprendre
imanol ça c'est sûr se débarrasser de ce
bref qui paralyse un petit peu ça tourne
peut-être un joyeux même qu'à rallier
prend tour être calme tout cas tous
rêvent six tours 6
ça peut être délicat pour les noirs
allez moi je le sens la gagner notre
maxime allez vous pouvez aller la
chercher celle là on risque d'en avoir
besoin parce que le match se pose pas
très bien finalement en réalité il ya
deux positions où on est mieux c'est
maxime et anna et deux positions on est
mal ses alliés vol n'avait pas vraiment
mieux les confortables je pense à coup
d'oeil
elle va nous faire le taf ana oui je
pense que l'évaluation de l'évaluation
donnée la vie peut exagérer quand même
je pense pas que je pense pas qu'il y
ait grand chose en fait pour pour les
noirs ils ont égalisé confort est
confortablement ça c'est sûr pas de
problème pour un homme mais pour gagner
ce sera pas facile moi j'aurais bien
évidemment j'ai s'inquiète un match 4
pour faire un petit clin d'oeil à tu
peux faire ça à rien as tu peux faire ça
a donc là quelques petits elle dit dans
mes pensées
mais bon même b3 damage soir ou à deux
parce que c'est si grave que ça soit je
suis ensuite de mettre une tourangelle
n'était pas si grave
attention cavaler h 5 tours 8
ouanna qui peut faire le taf police
fighter écoute c'est exactement le type
d'opposition qu'on la banalise et là
clairement il a un peu moins bien et
anne christophe duda et alors je vais te
donner
je vais vous donner quelques nouvelles
quand même des autres matchs avec la
chine qui est en train de perdre 1 6 2
nuls signé avec les noirs mais van gaal
très mal foutu en fait avec les blancs
contre artemiev eui fans qui oui fans
qui n' a pas spécialement davantage
contre gorillaz qui n'a donc la russie
qu'il pourrait entre guillemets ainsi à
des fêtes de l'europe et les états unis
du coup ça donne quoi ça pourrait vous
donner quelques cent ans à la russie
qu'on a peut-être enterré un peu vite
les etats-unis qui sont qui sont en
train de gagner contre contre le reste
du monde avec wesley so basse que les
deuxièmes et troisièmes échiquier h 10 s
était là c'était l'élève le problème
pour le sait cette équipe du reste du
monde et là ils sont en grosse
difficulté au moins au troisième et chic
et peut-être deuxième échiquier aussi
moi voilà c'était juste un petit point
sur les autres matches retour se servir
faut vraiment qu'on gagne il a commencé
par kobayashi ça m'étonne un petit peu
parce que pour g6 maintenant s'il fait
g5y la ville autorise la prise et apsys
pourquoi épopée l'autorisent
saint-maxime y avoir quelque chose tu es
par les noirs se sont débarrassés de la
faiblesse qu'il a pu oublier maxime non
mais assez n'y a rien du tout pour les
blancs ça c'est sur cette même l'envers
ce n'est quand même pas annonça t gagne
logiquement mieux mais bon qu'est prend
des six tours h4 faire ça à faire les
affaires du exactement qu'est ce qu'il a
raté maxime parce qu'il est s'il faisait
5 il est un petit peu mieux son humour
g7 alors ton g6 peut-être cavalli bref
cette rangée 4 et n 5
mais prise prise h5 finale
oui mais bon ok là c'est pas entre elles
a fait tour g7 pâton j'ai ici c'est g5l
franges et 5 il va est rare être franc
j'ai aimé la du coup maxime améliorer sa
situation la tour j'ai cette semaine on
a deux grosses bourdes d'afida mon avis
cavale et h67 tour 17
il ya quelque chose qu'on a dieu qu'on a
dur afin qu'on a dû rater auxquelles on
n'a pas dû penser qui leur a fait peur à
tous les deux et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour l'europe qui continuent à
robin maxime maintenant qu'il met une
grosse pression
alors est ce que les bonnes s'en sort
elle regarde sur m6 juste pour montrer
un truc un peu jolie bien voir ça à
trois points des fiscale et f5 et on
ramasse la tour alors ça qu'on y arrive
est ce que c'est vraiment gagnant sa
cavale et h5 est très embêtant parce
qu'on empêche de la poussée du pion
complètement là avec cavaliers quatre
échecs mais tu as raison c'est pas sûr
que ça soit gagnant ses cinq on essaie
de liquider un metteur en b cats ont
essayé de la dèche des trajets un
maximum d'options jamais facile
c'est gagnant ça je pensais plutôt que
ce sera gagnante pour les blancs mais
plutôt que c'est nul parce que le plan
nord et les plans de l'option https trop
avancé et qui pense qu'il ya par contre
je voyais là ils attendent sur id
agathon de l'autre côté avec le roi et
on sait pas trop ce que font les blancs
et d'accabler par des f4 pas page 3 il
ya un autre pion h derrière qu'il peut
faire un qui sont quand même là pour
faire le job et à nantes qui a fait
aussitôt qu'ils acceptent de rentrer
dans cette finale parce que sur gf
j'imagine il veut à tour j'ai six melons
etc à rijeka tâche 5 malheureusement
c'est marrant ça y va quand même perdre
6 mais il le fait que la tourangelle g7
est pas
angers 6 d'accord donc ils forcent à
temps et on peut pas faire comme ça pue
raté tous réussissent kf5 qui aurait
tour 17 tout simplement autour g6 ça
devrait rentrer dans cette finale maxime
qui pèse le pour et le contre
ça paraît logique est si doué tour au
cices le titre tactique
effectivement c'est pas si sagan est en
ondes à mon avis qui a raté tour 6 en
juin à tours j'ai cette même mais ça se
goupille bien alors on nous dit que duda
est en train de s'en sortir alors
peut-être un petit coup d'oeil à la
partie de notre police fighter
effectivement deux pions pour la qualité
donc ça va pour les noirs largement mais
les blancs devraient réussir
petit avantage noir quand même un mec
toxicomanes alors qu'elles sont c'est un
avantage matériel
enfin ça fait 5 points contre 4,7 en
quelque chose comme ça mais un peu tout
petit avantage matériel pour pour les
noirs mais ça suffira en principe ça
doit faire ne laissait pas passer de la
position est quand même très facile à
jouer pour pour les noirs avant que les
blancs isuppli sur touré fin avec le
cavalier parfaire tours et sète et leur
avons poussé des 4 c 5 et ses positions
pas agréable quand même alors qu'on nous
dit que hannah est en train de se faire
marcher dessus
ouais c'était pas visuellement ce des
pièces dans shoot est quand même pas mal
à part le roi est là c'est plein de
jouets en plus la tour qui paraît venger
un le pion qui peut partir wells en
train de mal de très mal se passer de
partout là ouais alors
mais on est dans le dur de partout sauf
maxime en réalité ouais ouais donc les
bonnes nouvelles à deux doigts de 23
proches de la défaite lé 24 est proche
de la défaite un ouais mais c'est pas
c'est pas moi c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout évident pour les blancs mais
c'est mon sens que c'est pas loin de le
gagner
et du coup maxime il a commencé par
cavalier f5 donc il veut pas avoir la
finale de conf regarder doit penser
qu'elle est nulle en force
probablement il a pu rater que vale h5
aussi parce qu'ils vont me voyez bien
qu'on peut arrêter le pion d'autres
manières mais subtil et plus haut plus
loin c'était plus embêtant je vous
prends le set et ça les change tout
ouais ouais enfin ça les change tout si
tu prend 1,7 point c'est tout tu vas
avec l'europe parce que si tu vends des
sites ou en b 6
pourquoi cet âge de perrache 5 tu vas tu
as pas encore tu l'as pas encore là la
russie peut être que c'est nul mais le
roi est un peu loin de l'action quand
même
malheureusement ouais j'suis pas sûr que
tout reprend j'ai cinq étaient
nécessaires mais on va voir ce qu'il a
décidé et il a pris le set sinon ils
peuvent aller appuyer d'accord mais il
peut aller en d6 aussi avec le roi ouais
le problème c'est que les blancs ou un
plan de plus mais évidemment bon j'aime
béguigné tour j'ai deux ans il va
rentrer là dedans ça ça va faire nul
ouais mauvais match mauvais match pour
le moment très mauvais match très
mauvais match
tout d'abord on va imaginer que ça fasse
nul les van leeuwen il peut la sauver
quand même mais bon on peut la sauver
alors un petit point sur les autres
matchs avec we fans qui est en train de
torturer gorillaz qui naquit peut-être
donc peut-être que la chine ne gagnera
pas non la chaîne allait perdre non même
oui je voulais dire peut-être que la
russie le ghana reste du monde
malheureusement ne sera pas d'exploit
pour nous non ça me forcerait à battre
les états unis en mettant un score 1 à
l'aller bas si on perd oui si on perd
contre l'un des petits mots il fera
alors qu'elle est ce que le départage
c'est
ce résultat particulier dans les virages
si ç'avait été résultat particulier ça
nous aurait avantagé puisque comme on a
gagné le match aller contre contre les
états unis
on aurait trois en plus on arrêtait
quasiment assuré d'être devant au
départage
il faut qu'on fasse match nul ici au
moins histoire d'avoir vraiment notre
destin entre les mains et pouvoir gagner
les deux matchs demain et pas avoir à
réfléchir au goal avérage ou quoi que ce
soit absolument surtout que surtout que
les états unis là ils vont encore mettre
3 1 probablement
et puis et puis attention là parce que
nos positions le score pourrait pourrait
enfler c'est à dire que oui on est des
ja aucune partie qui est encore qui a
encore perdu mais on est sur les trois
échecs y restant on est un peu moins
bien et faudrait pas que ça se
transforme
c'est sûr en 3d fait parce qu'après le
goal avérage façon maxime il a plus
aucune chance en désaccord sims a
affirmé ça c'est sûr
duda au mieux ça fera nul vraiment
dommage que maxime est pas testé à
nantes sur cette finale a pas tous
réussissent quand même avec cette tour
en a cinq
qu'est ce qui va provoquer à 6 ok ça me
paraît pas facile à jouer ça parte cette
position quand même à notre mine notre
ami polonais bon là il va falloir
espérer que dans les quelques minutes
qui viennent la situation s'améliore
parfois en c1 parfois un match qui
paraît très mauvais cinq minutes plus
tard change complètement de concision
c'est ce qui s'était passé au match
aller 1 mais a life ou la même chose oui
mais là ça semble encore plus compliquée
que la dernière fois que d'un autre côté
il ya aucune partie vraiment ou
je pense que c'est anna qui peut qui
peut qui peut nous mettre sur la bonne
voie et je propose qu'on se mette pour
mettre la caméra sur anna parce que
c'est elle qui peut qui peut faire la
différence voilà alors nommer quelqu'un
même auxerre qui est d'être la plus en
difficulté
ouais mais qui a peut-être la position
la plus retournable position à double
tranchant effectivement ça peut passer
dans chez les autres téléphones ou quoi
de toute façon vous chez doute à ça ça
fera au mieux nul alors que chez anna il
ya quand même pas mal de pièces sur
l'échiquier ya la vente à l'otan à l'est
celle qui peut qui peut retourner à la
situation
activement on va compter sur elle on va
compter sur elle jette un petit coup
d'oeil aux autres matches en attendant
n'ont pas de changement maxime donc ça
va faire nul à l'arrimer à tour en huit
romain plus de deux minutes côté un pic
ou nehru et là ça se passe vraiment très
très mal poids rognant qui est le tour
complètement morte
eric y aurait 10 rebonds l'a dit avant
le match que
que tu que tu la santé pas cette partie
de notre dame de 93 ans forment contre
contre le commandeur contre le maillon
faible jusque-là de cette nation scop
qui avait seulement 0 5 0 5 sur 5
et c'est vrai t'as raison des croix à
bas le lard en forme contre l'amant mais
forme saas j'ai pas pourquoi c'est un
truc qui donne des surprises un
classique ouais ça reste quand même un
classique ouais c'est ça rihanna temps à
récupérer à n'a du coup pas ce que c'est
c'est elle en fait elle a obligation de
gagner en réalité parce que tout ça
maxime il a fait nul c'est signé duda il
gagnera pas c'est sûr à 100% est en
réalité il faut cana gagne cette partie
pour ne pas perdre le match et encore et
encore ça peut ne pas suffire
oui et puisque comme comme gizeh où on
peut perdre ce match sur un score assez
lourd on est mal sur les trois échiquier
quand même
alors pour un as c'est peut-être pas si
grave effectivement c'est ça a l'air
d'aller mieux ouais elle a réussi à
échanger le fou qui posait problème et
tu vois sur un coup comme damas je crois
que propose l'ordinateur je pense qu'à
ça il faut qu'elle parte pour dames b4
quelque chose un faux pas qu'elles
échangent les dames 1 ouais faux frais
c'est de toute façon
fonds récupérés le match mais
malheureusement qui on prend gestion
pranger six dames h6 ensuite tu vois et
ce que la dame noire va pas être obligé
de revenir en défense pour s'échanger
n'inquiète pas inquiète pas adam
resteront en attaque mais on se
débrouillera autrement brico valora mais
là je pense vraiment les faire d'amd 4 à
la vue de la physionomie du match sinon
davantage 3 c'était clairement un coup
candidat mais là tu dois partir de
l'autre côté c'est de faire dam des deux
qui étaient trois et ça peut faire peur
mais ça peut aller très vite robin huit
ont été joués déjà balafre a été jouée
ouais d'accord à la qui est concentré
mais allez la dame des quatre sacres ou
plus rapidement quand même roma ouais il
faut que je garde les dames c'est le
jette un oeil aux autres d'échiquier
ouais ça tu comprend rapidement que les
autres échiquiers justin ont refait
parce que ça il va la tenir ou pas on
n'en sait rien et étudie les vols mais
bon on est complètement foutu mais
puisque surtout vacature à 6 c'est
vraiment dommage parce que duda serait
peut être un point rapide mais à la
place ce service se transformer en
défaite donc écoute aller à dame c'est
la dernière espoirs dans ce match oui il
nous faut une victoire d'anna aller 1 à
d'amd qui est rapidement là il faut
absolument garder les dames on n'a pas
le droit actuel est inférieur parce que
le pion cesserait faible avec f4
derrière donc s'il te plaît en a gardé
d'am dam des quatre magasins en d2 bref
si tu dois gagner en plus donc
historique dame b 4 pions projet 6 ou
même rouages et de celui partout rachat
ça s'appelle john tu es trop les na waie
on a vu pire
on a vu pire on dit bien pire en la
elle sait qu'il faut pousser va elle
peut regarder les échiquiers en petit
donc elle peut théoriquement savoir
qu'il faut qu'il faut pousser vrai
effectivement elle peut savoir qu'il
faut pousser alors attends je vais juste
faire un kit demande c'est de meublé
pendant ses deux fers conforama pendant
une petite maddie d'argent non ça je
voulais juste demandé si elle voulait
passer du coup j'ai fait un petit de moi
je sais pas on verra
ok alors j'essaie de voir un petit peu
des questions dans le chat c'est qu'il
faut pousser dans on espère que on
espère on espère qu'elle le sait je
pense qu'elle a un sens de regarder les
autres des autres partis mais que de
toute façon la finale n'est pas bonnes
donc ici elle a toutes les raisons du
monde de garder les dames et j'imagine
que bon une compétition par équipes ils
ont dû rendre facile l'accès aux autres
the rope aux autres parties du match
pour tous les joueurs attends je suis en
train de récupérer maxime passe trop de
temps ça se trouve elle a reçu une
proposition venue avec la veille d'un
match 3 et elle est comme elle est pas
très bien elle a envie de prendre mais
[Musique]
sur b4 us de your head and bess cinq
échecs donc non paroisse de plutôt âgés
2 et avec la tour qui débarque en h1 il
y avait une jolie classe en fait avec
d'un match 4 il y avait une jolie menace
c'était dames feront tour g3 par
l'échangé les dames
ah non bon alors un peu on peut dire
adieu à toute chance de gain est donc
c'est un match qui sera un match qui
sera perdue la passe carreau n'y a
vraiment rien à faire à mon avis non
c'est fini la sas a fini le match
annoncé plus qu'un miracle qui nous
ferait
non là c'est ingagnable duda c'est
ingagnable les bonnes
c'est un sauvable à leur tour b2 ce que
c'est un sauvage s'est jamais finale
deux tours des fois et ça a l'air ça a
l'air complètement insauvable à 7 tours
c'est cette approche 4 était à tour et
cournon mais ça parait vraiment
impossible un nom cela c'est
complètement
c'est complètement perdus web de
plusieurs plusieurs manières
probablement web 9,5 salesse tours l2
quand même alors tours l2 qu'un
important parce que surtout reprend j'ai
de tout de suite car du tour c'est 7 qui
aurait forcé le roi à repartir sur la
huitième rang j'ai donc d'abord un petit
coup des chèques et sur cinq qui va
prendre de plongée 2 et maintenant s'il
a tout refait chaque au moins le roi
peut aller de l'avant en g6 ça reste
probablement complètement perdu mais
sommes cinq à mon avis ce n'était pas le
plus technique mais bon je peux me
tromper aussi peut-être à la revend à
faire un truc un petit peu technique en
fait on va récupérer
maxime donc on va perdre les caméras
pour la fin du match on va récupérer
on va récupérer maxime ce que je vais
faire c'est que je vais t'envoyer sur
facebook un lien sur une réunion zoom
donc sur vous pour récupérer l'autre
rappel et comme ça andorran maxime tous
les deux d'accord
donc je te laisse une seconde je
t'envoie lien tout de suite sur facebook
on se retrouve dans une petite minute
heure ok ça marche avant de te quitter
up donc à tout de suite je t'envoie le
lien dans quelques secondes
ok donc les gars à une petite seconde
donc on va récupérer
maxime et romain très rapidement pour
pour la fin du match face on a bien
compris que le match était plié comme ça
ça nous fera une une petite interview
avec maxime donc quatre caméras nom va
on va pas faire ça comme ça ce serait
trop compliqué à faire mais on va
profiter quand même d'avoir maxime qui
est quand même le numéro un français le
est le numéro un de cette équipe
donc c'est quand même assez intéressant
de la voir mais c'est vrai que le match
semble semble très très compliqué
donc donc on va on va pas s'embêter à
garder la caméra on va plutôt récupérer
maxime assure sur la kam hon les votes
qui tente une défense enfin qu'on va
retrouver tout de suite
alors il va devoir fusent brancher son
sont romain et on va l'avoir revendre
est de retour je suis dans le tour
est-ce que tu m'entends alors je
t'entends j'ai pas encore ta caméra mais
c'est pas forcément très grave
maintenant je peux pas je peux pas
lancer la caméra sur zoom parce qu'elle
est déjà lancée sur notre faim tu fermes
l'autre l'autre hong lei donc je ne
ferme et normalement ça devrait pouvoir
la lancer
tu vois déjà mon écran j'ai l'impression
que c'est fini pour pour les vols
d'essai finale deux tours parfois même
si à deux pions qui est là ça devrait
marcher
voilà c'est bon et voilages et récupérer
complètement
c'est complètement perdus pour pour pour
les vannes sur un petit tempo de plus
avec ténors la fin je vais jouer mais le
roi va repartir
la position serait nulle si la tour
blanche étant à 8
dépenser 7 ouais mais très orangé 7 h 7
et il n'y aurait pas de gains mais là
ouais là c'est là ces marins
là ces morts portent à 91 des caméras
maintenant sur vous ou moi j'ai pas trop
bref je vais je vais là je la récupère
et et maxime arrive c'est ça va écouter
je pense j'espère j'espère j'espère
j'espère devrait arriver tout du monde
et finalement la chine qui va gagner
contre la russie complètement retourné
le match sont forts ces chinois ils sont
forts ces chinois au moins n'a réussi
reviendra pas dans nos pattes c'est déjà
ça j'ai envie de te dire on ça
c'est déjà ça mais bon c'est pas
forcément le le plus important ça s'est
fini à la parce que l'important c'est
les états unis rehamna qui peuvent pas
elles valent gagnera jamais san
non non on a un match sans espoir pour
une grosse gaffe d'arrêt krishna mais
pour espérer quoi que ce soit
alors à temps fort ici ça écrira le lien
à maxime ce qu'on me dit attends tu
perds et maxime ça j'ai envoyé ma ti
j'arrive qui nous fait perdre pas mal de
matches ont déjà hier on a perdu un
match c'est un match complètement amical
contre une équipe canadienne mais il a
perdu notre première et chic y ait un
petit alors c'est pas lui qui a fait
perdre mais là on perd on perd les
matches en sont alors on va on va la
voir rejoindre tout de suite bientôt je
vois déjà sa caméra
donc je crois qu'il arrive sa livrée
style à lui j'étais en train de discuter
avec vichy de la portière alors qu'est
ce qu'il raconte vichy bat il était
inquiet et si tu veux qu'ils racontent
d'autres mais là de toute façon ça
ferait aucune différence en fait ouais
on se fait déchirer un ouais c'est vrai
encore battre les us et on a un mauvais
départage as agence à rien j'ai pas par
gmail que si on bat les us on est pas
mal puisqu'on les a battus zhao
ouais mais je crois que c'est pas le
sait pas de partages particulier dans
wells et le boulot de rage donc là ils
viennent encore de gagner 3 à oui c'est
une bonne nouvelle non mauvaise journée
c'est cher que la chine a été dominée
mais la vendée quand même des regrets à
avoir
et alors un moment donné tu as commencé
un petit peu à le
rouleau compressé dans la partie comme
tafer quand elle commence à pousser g4
h4 etc
oui après tout les huit gp album puisque
j'ai vu ce qui les accueillent à chis
pour g 6 7 5
ah c'est ça qu'on a ratée est d'accord
sur tout rejet 6 tu voulais faire f 5
parce qu'on se demandait si justement on
se demandait si tu avais raté quelque
chose
f5 tour points à 6 h saint et que tu lui
en ferme la tour oui d'accord mais en
fait ça marchait pas j'aurais dû juste
jouer g5l people d'enrichir notre mieux
à ce moment là ouais j'ai cinq cet
effort et qu'est ce que tu penses de la
compétition en général maxime non c'est
intéressant alors après on souffre entre
guillemets dans des avantages c'est ya
pas de on va dire en âne
on a une équipe européenne bon on
s'entend bien avec les joueurs mais on
n'a pas le centre guillemets le support
d'un pays qui permet évidemment se
motiver dans des compétitions comme les
olympiades ou là celle-là on sent que
les chinois sont très motivés et qu'ils
jouent les prépas qui sont tu veux dire
que les collines une aide on va dire du
gouvernement au final parler sans parler
d'une aide du gouvernement des joueurs
qui sont aussi habitués à jouer ensemble
alors que la russie est là on découvre
encore mais c'est intéressant comme
expérience
franchement c'est plutôt kiffant après
c'est beaucoup trop long comme
qu'annonce jetant en cuir un petit peu à
force c'est un peu long non mais après
on a des parties intéressantes mais j'ai
toujours considéré que 25 lui dit
c'était une cadence un peu bâtarde
c'est ni trop ni ni du rapide il est en
fait et c'est trop lent pour être triées
par rapport à bill thomas b 15 + 10 où
tu peux mais même 15 + dj temps d'un
navire c'est un peu trop longue donc et
tu peux pas être profond tu peux pas
faire comme riche que réfléchir une
heure sur une position et joué des
coupes
je veux dire cette finale par exemple
contre vichy je suis sûr que je me pose
beaucoup plus de problèmes en partie
longue lente ou en partie blitz bref
voilà en partie longue parce que j'ai le
temps d'attaquer fin de dettes précis et
en partie blitz parce que il a pas le
temps de défendre
toi tu verrais quoi du coup comme
cadence 15 + 10 ou carrément 10 + 2 1 4
5 ou en tout cas vrai bon produit à 6
c'est quoi ces 10 + 2 ouais mais aucun
n'est pas en pros de chasse ligne mais
je vais bien réfléchir un petit peu mais
25 + 10 c'est vraiment trop lent déjà
sur l'échiquier c'est trop long alors
sur internet c'est un cauchemar un peu
long et les pauses entre les matches je
trouve pas que c'est un peu long aussi
nous en tant que spectateur ça nous
paraît long comme pause mais après pour
les joueurs est ce que c'est important
pour se régénérer important puisqu'en
fait le problème c'est que parfois on
est obligé de changer l'équipe
donc ça s'est fait à quel moment la
composition vous là vous la connaissez à
quel moment un on la connaît en fait on
bon l'a fait la veille généralement mais
on peut faire des changements
peut-être que 12 à gagner ça c'est
miraculeux a tant fait voir sa taille
complètement gagnant maintenant
effectivement courant et la fera sonner
peut-être mais bon problème c'est que
anna elle était très bien et la cgper
déjà perdre deux matches seulement deux
et demi un an et demi ça permettrait de
pas de recoller un petit pot des
partages avec les états unis
ouais m'attends à l escale à quelque
chose de moi là non
mais le problème c'est yards et k3 c'est
simple qui va arriver ouais c'est
catherine je sais pas quoi elle a
échangé encore un petit espoir par
exemple 3d annoncée tient pas mais je
voulais enfin déjà au moins la tour en
archi ça peut-être permettre des petits
attend à quatre peut-être elle peut
protéger les tours peut-être à peut
faire ça et ça 4 je pense que c'est pas
terrible
enfin automne tu pouvais jouera des
quatre tours h3c cinq tombes et 8 et
maintenant à 4
on peut même le gagner ce match assure
une gaffe ouais bon là on va pas
n'exagérons rien mais 1 2 partout dans
un sacré miracle mal au match aller on
avait été très chanceux oui et puis on a
eu pas mal de chance aussi
même aujourd'hui contre la chine le dire
mon parti je sais qu'on a perdu le match
au final mais les notes parti c'est un
sketch la sedona que j'ai l'impression
d'avoir fait plutôt une bonne partie là
par contre vichy 15 deuxième question
contre contre vichy quand il te fait m6
à la fin est ce que tu a considéré le
coup tours 6 ouais un pion prend
pourtant dé 6,3 apprentis f5 et là au
début j'avais trois des cinq qui est
rangé cette tranche quatre cahiers h5
oui les sanctions n'arrive pas à y
croire c'est sans doute nulle quand même
mais il a réussi ce qui est projet c'est
3 m6 et au final c'est moi qui dois
faire gaffe d'accord oui on pensait que
même après que peut avoir des cinq
cabanes et h55
c'était peut-être encore nul c'est
probablement encore mieux mais alors on
ne pose des questions sur kasparov à
temps mais ça commence à aller
complètement la regarde ouais ça va être
mieux hilti miracle ainsi hockey au
moins ça nous attend et encore pour ses
sept tentatives possibles
mais même cette finale avait nulle et
elle prend avec le tour non mais c'est
vrai mais là le truc c'est que je vais
jouer par exemple tour à deux je pense
et tu vas bon après on verra mais je
pense que c'est encore lui mais ce ne
sera pas facile à défendre face si elle
prendre cette tour là c'est facile on
est d'accord quand on échangerait bien
vérifier que vos problèmes ces quelques
données en train de donner des chances
la whey 7 doit encore
qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il faut en
fait là je rate un truc
il avait juste un pion une qualité plus
non ah ouais mais il a ouais bon il
décide de nous faire vibrer un peu plus
encore la gagner il aurait tourin
j'aurais joué là est en fait le truc
c'est peut-être ça peut encore gagner
parce que même en étant au nom salerne
humain ne va pas pk 3b trouvera ses
trois et amené le roi qua non mais b3 je
voulais jouer pour justement aux 3,6
après j'ai dû plonger quand même qui
fait alors c'est la dernière partie 1 a
réussi à faire nul
ouais allez un petit effort de duda les
amis on croit qu'on peut pas commencer
par un petit coup de tocsin échec pour
gagner en tempo di ielsi chiche
l'important c'est très important donc le
roi c'est obligé de rester sur la
cinquième en géant suite g4 très vite sa
présidente idée maintenant c'est juste
de de réussir à défendre enfin elle
empêcher la poussée du pion b ensuite
parce que pourrait mais bon s'il faudra
pas perdre le changer même dans les
champs du cavalier puisque le rhum blanc
serait trop loin j'ai eu trois ça doit
être gagnant quand même mais bon une
demande et parce qu'en plus il ya
d'équipier regarde son équipe à fond
ouais on skype est tout chaud le poster
mon petit message alors attends qu elle
qui parle c'était une bonne nouvelle ça
lyon qui peut commencer à partir angers
4 one ont érodé de rodez donne bien sûr
ron dennis nona ora p4 pour ses 7 août
est g4
est-ce que kasparov il discute un peu
sur le chat de l'équipe
non mais ils nous appellent pour nous
engueuler à la fin des matches ouais
c'est bien lui ça je te font engueuler
là pour la nul contre allende pas loin
pas encore mais je pense pas que je me
fais engueuler j'ai fait plutôt une
bonne partie juste pas de chance non
par contre la partie contre ding mais il
l'est pas et elle pas besoin de
m'engueuler je me suis engueulé tout
seul et qu'est ce que tu as raté
d'ailleurs quand tu as joué dams est
qu'elle prend des 5es faut prendre 5 en
fait j'avais vous prend des cinq tours
des 8 et c'est super chaud donc là ça va
je voulais pas rentrer dans la finale
avec 4 avec un piano mon ami qui doit
qui doit être nul mais du coup j'ai
choisi la plus dure en plus j'étais
énervé ensuite parce que quand il m'a
donné des chances j'ai vu que hier trois
échecs mais mais j'ai joué trop vite
j'ai joué trop vite
damman et l3 c'est un bouc perpétuelle
la la le cavaliere a été loin du roi
pour faire échec donc il va falloir
envoyer le pion dans les gares ouais
maintenant c'est l'heure d'envoyer le
pian la g3 g4 faut juste pas faire g3 g4
en fait sujet 3 kg 5 g 4 kgs m6 et j'ai
cinq et quatre échecs qui la jugeaient 4
bon après il n'a pas beaucoup de temps
mais ça doit être gagnant faut pas
qu'elle salaire quand même assez
facilement gagnant avec le roi comme ça
oui le renoir est coupée ce qui vous
êtes beaucoup puisque celle ci le roi
noir était par exemple en d5 ce serait
très facilement nul le roi arriverait le
tromper frey le chantage soit sur la
tour soit sur le roi et le 2 est comme
ça en même temps ensuite d'attaquer le
lédat c'est d'ailleurs tout aussi un
échec peut-être qu'il aurait dû aller en
d5 avec le roi ou est probable au mien
l'appareil dispose pas jouer g5 ne peut
pas prendre encore envoyé pions parce
que leurs ouailles dans le carré 1
malheureusement on n'a pas besoin non
plus parce qu'ils auraient cavaliers 4
et schlag la robe et deux au tour élite
voilà on rappelle que roy kappeler
contre 3 tours cet unique théorique
ouais c'est nul sauf si lecavalier
arrive pas à revenir
près du roi des rois b4g 5 est
maintenant tous les sacrifices sont
possibles parce que le roi serait plus
dans le carré mais je crois que quand
même pas besoin de sacrifier un nom